what up everybody it is
august 5th a beautiful friday
welcome
nice to see everybody
we are here with a very special guest
named uh blac blake lemoine
who is yes yes
now you may not recognize the name but
you definitely know who he is because it
has been a huge story circulating for
the past couple months blake
uh was the
ai engineer
um so
whistleblower
yeah yeah so i was a software engineer
at google and i also was an ai
researcher there um
i was working on a completely unrelated
team
when there was a need for an ai bias
expert
so there's a system at google that's
been being developed for several years
called lambda
and it was getting towards the end
stages where they were looking at more
public release stuff and so they were
doing some safety testing at the end and
they needed an ai bias expert to test it
for bias
and that's where i came in to
that part of the development so you guys
may recognize the the lambda that's
google's advanced what does it say it
stands for language model for dialogue
applications right and so this is this
language uh uh
ai or bot or whatever you want to say
um and there and you basically broke
this story that you thought that this ai
machine or i don't know if there's a
system machine that works yeah
that was sentient yeah and these
incredible transcripts were that you
were posting of these really
philosophical in-depth conversations you
guys were having
so
yeah um i want to build up to that but i
want to go back a little bit
so uh
basically i'm just curious about your
background like where were you born yeah
so i was oh sorry hold on a second just
my buddy gabe he calls in on friday hey
gabe what's up
whoo
yeah he just checks in on fridays no
yeah this is his name is white claw gabe
gabe whoo
yeah
[Applause]
happy friday baby
it's friday baby [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah all right
well i have a guest here blake um
he's an ai uh ethic ethics engineer
a specialist
do you have any do you want to ask him
anything or or should we just
ai
ai blake
yeah
hey i play what's going on
i like that boy
cool man what's
oh
going
watching the terminator baby
that's it that's a good idea like any
thoughts on terminator
uh well i i don't see that as very
likely no uh there's no
going there's very few guns at google
right
[ __ ]
oh my god i'm gonna spit out my coffee
[Applause]
all right listen gabe i'ma let you go
cause we're about to have a conversation
but i thank you for calling that was
that was fanta i just love to see your
face on fridays all right buddy
it's friday baby
all right take care buddy have a good
weekend okay
all right all right talk to you all
right bye white clock gabe everybody
great guy
good guy
yeah so um i was asking you where
where were you born kind of yeah so i
grew up in a little bitty village in
louisiana called mooreville
from there i went to college for a
little while at the university of
georgia
didn't do too great first time around
ended up failing out joined the us
military uh served four years in the u.s
army i joined right after 9 11. i left
was that a patriotic joint yeah it was
like our country's under attack i just
failed out of school need something to
do with my life should go and defend the
country uh and then i left right after
they court-martialed me
right so that's interesting yeah so
basically you grew up in a small town
how many people bro uh
wow that is small yeah is this kind of
like the corn fields and stuff that you
see in the movies kind of thing uh by
like
more bayous and you know fields stuff
like that right and so um
it's kind of a little town where
everybody knows each other assuming yeah
yeah
do you still have family there probably
they're probably all talking about you
at this point now right uh well yeah so
i still have family in the area lots of
friends uh then after the military i
went back to louisiana i lived in
lafayette louisiana where i went to
college for 10 years and then i moved to
the bay area i see so how so basically
you live in this little town and then at
what point did you leave uh
um i mean like
the first time i kind of like left home
was to go i went to a residential high
school uh in louisiana called the
louisiana school for math science and
the arts you actually live in a dorm at
high school
uh attend high school there
so i guess i was about 14. so you were
kind of gifted in a way but even back
then you knew you were doing advanced
courses and stuff yeah were you were you
always interested in kind of the ai
stuff or engineering or interesting yeah
yeah
um in high school
the three kind of career paths i was
looking at were either going to be
quantum physics genetic engineering
or artificial intelligence
and i tried out all three
in high school i did quantum chemistry
research at texas tech
ended up getting a publication
out of that
but i decided that the actual nuts and
bolts work of doing quantum research
wasn't for me what did you publish about
oh
it's it's a paper on alh3 plus ion
bonding energy levels oh yeah i mean
it's like
yeah um
we were doing all kinds of like
uh simulated models of figuring out
energy states of different molecular
geometries stuff like that
really interesting and engaging stuff
i bet if you're know all about that
stuff i bet it is
was it hard growing up in like a small
city kind of like you you seem
exceptionally intelligent and you knew
it at a small
at a young age did you feel out of place
ever in that i mean or you knew you were
gonna
do something
i was always um you know always sticking
out like a sore thumb always you know
but i made my own way had lots of
friends
well at least by high school figured out
you know okay here's how i relate to
other people i had lots of friends did
lots of activities i got into theater in
middle school and that helped me with
social circles and stuff like that
but yeah i knew i wasn't gonna stay
there right that you know i was gonna
find my way somewhere else to work in
science in one way or another did you
know that at a young age where you're
like i i this is too small town for me
yeah well i mean like from a young age i
knew i wanted to go into the sciences
wow that's so interesting and so you
went to this kind of uh science based
high school yep and out of high school
where did you go after that i went to
university of georgia okay and i was a
double major in genetics and computer
science ambitious yeah
um
that year though uh the university of
georgia was also the number two party
school oh in the nation uh and me coming
from a little bitty town in louisiana
and then you know residential high
school uh i kind of changed my major to
partying and you don't get to keep your
scholarship if you do that wow so you
had a scholarship like a full
scholarship yeah wow
and so
tell me about that you went there
and how long before you kind of got lost
in the party scene oh i think a few
months within months right um but it
took me about a year a year and a half
um
before it was like okay this isn't
working
time to
get out and i was working as a computer
programmer you know just doing kind of
odd jobs and working for different
little small firms
then 911 happened and i decided to join
the military
so did you not did you just not like
university did you feel like it wasn't
for you or you were just got so
distracted by all the fun stuff going on
yeah it was 100 i just got distracted i
just got off track yeah fraternities and
stuff like that no uh it was more it was
like i didn't go with the greek party
scene it was the geek party oh yeah
that's awesome
dropping acid what were you guys up to
uh so at one or two points yeah oh yeah
i'm curious what's that like for a guy
with a with a big old brain like you
oh so now we're gonna go directly into
like the more psychedelic and mystic
stuff yeah well i like you know i think
it's all part of who you are and i want
to get an idea for for
who i'm talking to you know before we
dive into the
so the
way i look at things like psychedelics
is
when you go through the world when you
see everything around you you're doing a
lot of top-down processing you have a
lot of expectations of what you're going
to see and you kind of apply those
expectations and whatever the heck is in
front of you you shove it into that mold
and you understand what you're seeing
today through the lens of what you
learned yesterday
psychedelics kind of break that
connection a good bit so you're not
coming to your perceptions of reality
with any kinds of preconceived notions
it gives you a chance
to see the world through new eyes
um you know look at it through the
kaleidoscope of wonderland uh see things
the way the cheshire cat would see
things right and then you know you come
down
and you have to reintegrate that back
into the normal every day how you go
through things so it sounds like it was
like a transformative kind of experience
for you definitely wow was that the
thing or when you say parting i'm just
curious was it like drinking was it like
acid so i have mushrooms i only did uh
acid a few times uh no i was drinking
yeah it was just partying just good old
college party yeah yeah
yeah it's scary were you scared to do it
at first the acid i mean it's kind of
what it's kind of intimidating right um
after i did it a couple of times i got
scared of it like
once i had certain i didn't have any
preconceptions of what it would be like
so it was like oh here's a new thing to
try sure i'll try it and then after i
had some really intense experiences i'm
like oh wait no hold up oh it breaks all
this wow
wow
usually it's the other way around i find
that really interesting
yeah what was it that that what was it
inside those acid trips that
gave you pause about doing it again well
the the one that like i i really hit the
brakes on was one that went real like
you did save a bad trip
um
when you get eaten by a giant naga for
several hours wow you know that what is
a naga a giant snake creature with arms
is that what was oh yeah yeah i get that
i wouldn't want to do that again yeah
feeling like you're being digested by a
snake is not fun
wow no
yeah i've had bad trips too i don't
really mess with that stuff anymore so
i'm i'm right there with you i've never
been eaten by a snake though on a bad
trip
damn how much acid you take dude
jesus
that's good [ __ ] wait by the way we have
a picture of the naga oh like this
yeah and now imagine is that a world of
warcraft reference oh it's older they're
older mythological creatures but they
are yeah world of warcraft but now
imagine one of those uh 70 feet tall
and then
were you were you with people or by
yourself uh yeah i was with people who
basically came and babysat okay thank
god that's good you had good friends
yeah i did
so he went to college he had too much
fun
got distracted and then did you leave or
did they kick you out uh well i mean
they didn't like i wasn't kicked out it
was funding you know i lost my
scholarship
i can't do this yeah it's why did you
lose the scholarship because you weren't
meeting the grade yeah it wasn't
and then at that point it became a
serious conversation between me and my
parents like was it worth
going to college at that time was i
ready for that
um and i wasn't i wasn't attending
classes regularly like i should have i
wasn't studying like i should have just
um wasn't disciplined enough
um
you know in a way it's kind of crazy to
send a
18 year old out like that because i in
the same in the same way i think i
wasn't
ready for it either
but um
but it's it's nice to see the kind of
that all the different paths you can
take so a couple months you decide i'm
i'm not gonna pay for this yeah and
that's right around the time that 911
yeah so i like the spring semester was
my last semester at uga and then that
fall
was
when 9 11 happened and i decided okay
let me go ahead and
try out the military
and
the big you know bonus from that is
through military training and life in
the military i gained enough discipline
to where when i went back to school
after i left the military or you know
after they kicked me out um
yeah i was able to actually
apply myself at college and do well
so
that's really interesting that you
joined after 9 11.
did you have this sense of patriotism
before or during or what like the
emotion that pushed you towards that
well i mean it was a big wave of
patriotism that everyone got hit by and
i had always admired people who served
in the military
and
at that point it felt like you know our
country's under attack let me join the
military help defend our country
yeah i can imagine coming from a small
town there's probably a lot of people
that go to the military after high
school right that's pretty common yeah
yeah
so you went in the military you did boot
camp yep you did all that
and how does it work you go into boot
camp and then you decide or they decide
for you where you're going to go no so
it all depends on your contract there's
all kinds of things you can get
guaranteed and the things i got
guaranteed in my contract were
what
training i would get i was a generator
mechanic
and where i would be stationed which was
germany
okay wow
so you basically learned to be a
mechanic like physically
yeah so generator mechanics in the army
you have to fix the engines that drive
the generators as well as the electrical
systems that
um control them and produce the
electricity is that difficult to learn
is that like a high level engineering no
no i mean it's basic electronics okay
okay okay um not that it sounds fancy
yeah it means it takes
three or four months of training to
learn
okay here's how you read an electrical
diagram here's how you actually repair
the systems
um
but then beyond that like what i
actually did in iraq when i was there
was ran the electricity for 10 cities we
would come in set up a base
we would pull out the generators that
we're going to run the electricity for
the base and then i would run the
electrical lines make sure everything
was load balanced and make sure
that everything had the right voltage
so you went to germany that's where you
learned to do this and then and then
they sent you to iraq no no stationed in
germany the training uh base for uh
generator mechanics is at aberdeen
proving grounds in maryland
so at what point did you get sent uh to
iraq um it was so the war in iraq
started in march of 03 i was there in
may of 03. i see right at the beginning
and you you setting up like massive
generators or what are they burning to
produce diesel just diesel yeah and
they're
pretty large like about the size of this
table in length and width and about
seven feet tall and that's enough to
produce electricity for like our five
feet tall yeah for a whole base no no no
that that'll
run like one mechanic shop or maybe
it'll run
um 40 tenths wow wow okay interesting a
lot of diesel burning yeah so like one
single company might have eight of those
for the different things they're doing
so at what point um so you're out in
iraq
and we talked about this briefly before
but at a certain point you got
a court martial yeah that was after i
came back uh when i came back from
germany i'd seen a bunch of messed up
stuff in iraq it was right at the
beginning so like the time when abu
ghraib and all that was happening
abu ghraib wasn't the only messed up
stuff happening in iraq i saw a bunch of
the other things that were going on and
i kind of wrestled with it like what to
do about that
and
in i guess it was 2004 2005 time frame i
decided to talk to some reporters i
connected with some vietnam veterans who
had been
active duty war protesters in the
vietnam era
and
uh told the story of things i had seen
what just to get an idea it was like
american war crime kind of stuff
so
whether or not it classifies as a war
crime that's for lawyers and yeah just
to decide people being treated really
badly soldiers
soldiers behaving in ways
that the american public would not want
soldiers
yeah wow
so i can imagine that you know you went
out there for this patriotic duty and
then all of a sudden you're like what
the [ __ ] are we doing here and now yeah
this fool not only um seeing how we were
fighting it but it's like what did iraq
have to do with 9 11. it starts to set
in yeah yeah things like that and then
seeing
how we're treating people over or we
were treating people over there from all
reports that i've heard uh after
that early phase of the war america did
actually change how they were fighting
and fought more honorably after that oh
wow that a lot of it just had to do with
not knowing what to do or how to engage
with that kind of war at that point in
time was there a lot was there a general
feeling amongst your
your uh
colleagues or fellow soldiers that were
feeling the same way as you or most
people just would
oh there's a wide variety and everything
from people who
you know were sympathetic to the iraqi
people and the kinds of things that they
were being put through
all the way through like full-on racists
who just wanted to kill as many iraqis
as they could yeah
and like those are rare like i said it's
just those are the the tent poles on
either side and everything in between
most people were somewhere in the middle
doing their job serving their country
and just finding a way to get through
the day yeah did you find though that
like these these super
you know end of the spectrum psychos
they just want to kill iraqis did they
find a safe haven in the army
uh no no like
they got found out pretty quickly and
you know were shown the door eventually
it's not
like what is wanted by the us military
it's simply something that did exist in
small numbers
so at a certain point you remove you uh
return to the u.s yeah is that when your
tour ended or how does that work uh no
so i went back to germany because i was
based in germany when the tour in iraq
ended went back to germany uh and that's
where i became an anti-war protester got
court-martialed uh was actually put in
prison in germany first uh
i was sentenced to six months in prison
or seven months or something i only
served six
uh
but then when they put me in prison in
germany
there's a whole bunch of german war
protesters who came around the prison
and were protesting outside
of the prison so they
shipped me from germany to the united
states and i finished the prison
sentence at fort sill they shipped you
away because you were causing a ruckus
there yeah wow yeah there was actually
an email like in my discharge papers i
got all of the paperwork that had to do
with it and the general in charge of
europe at that time sent an email to the
warden uh of that prison that said get
that [ __ ] off my continent
wow congratulations
was there a specific thing that you saw
where you're like man [ __ ] this i can't
do this because making the decision
to
become a you know a protester of the war
while being an active member of the army
is obviously a big risk
i mean but it wasn't any one thing it
was just an accumulation of a whole
bunch of things
uh that
kind of sat with me
and was kind of like in the back of my
mind festering the actual catalyst that
made me decide to
become an anti-war protester
was one weekend
me and my ex-wife
we were married at the time
went and saw cabaret in frankfurt and
have you ever seen that play no
so it takes place in nazi germany and is
right before um the nazis really take
power and there's a bunch of characters
in that play who are decent people
and who aren't opposing the human rights
violations that are happening in germany
and what got to me is that a bunch of
the things that they were saying as
dialogue in that play to justify
their you know passive compliance
with the same kinds of things that i was
saying
to say hey look you know i'm just one
person
it's
why take this on you know there's no way
to change the like those kinds of
speaking directly to you yeah and so i'm
just hearing the kinds of excuses that i
was giving myself coming out of
the mouths of these characters and it
really brought home it's like no no the
way that you
actually prevent
human rights abuses is
by speaking up
so by this is so interesting because i
think there's such a direct parallel to
what what you're into now with google
um but
so
at basically how did you
break the seal so to speak was it a big
deal
at the time for you to speak out i mean
to the point where there was protesters
outside your your hotel and stuff so um
the
actual catalyst there
is
i contacted journalists like i
directly
uh at that point in time you actually
sent physical letters right to people so
i sent like a letter describing what i
had seen and the story i wanted to tell
to a whole bunch of journalists the new
york times is the one they ended up
picking up the story oh so was it was a
big deal probably at the time yeah um
that from there i got put in contact
with some anti-war resistance
organizations in germany and they
connected me with some vietnam veterans
what was the headline of the article do
you remember oh i don't remember right
now was it a big one was like front near
the front page kind of thing yeah no but
it the new york times article was an
aggregation of
the story of like four or five different
service members who were telling similar
stories did they protect your identity
at all or were you like no i don't care
that's my story well at that point um so
the same day that i mailed out those
letters i handed in a letter of
resignation to my platoon sergeant i see
and uh you can't do that well that's
what he said yeah he's like you don't
you don't resign from the army yeah and
then my response was i just did right so
what happens when you do that um well
the base commander like my my unit
commander tried to figure out what to do
about it brought me into the office
talked to me about it and when i was
insistent that no i quit
a procedure started that eventually led
to me getting court-martialed
what is it is there a court martial so
what happens you're there in the office
they're trying to figure it out oh it's
a trial
so you had an actual trial with the is
there like jury or just military members
the
in a special court martial which is what
i had you can request a jury but it's
not a jury of your peers you get a jury
of officers i believe a frank colonel or
that doesn't sound fair it's not yeah
um so the
uh i waived the right to a jury trial
and just the judge was the jury did was
the judge coming down on you pretty hard
is it a military judge yeah
it's all it's all military so they're
all kind of yeah well i mean the super
bias the crime they charged me with
isn't even a crime outside of the
military right failure to obey a lawful
order from a commissioned officer right
and so was the judge coming down hard on
you or they're just like i mean that
seems like a somewhat ordinary the
charge i mean
with the specific sentence the judge
gave
um
basically they put me in prison for the
rest of my military contract okay which
was how long uh my mission was three and
a half years so at that point at that
point i was like three years in so it
was just the last six months of my
contract so you were in prison a
military prison for sick for six months
yep well
is there any other punishment like i
know they you get paid and they pay for
your college and there's other benefits
to serving the military do they take any
of those away from you
um
with a bad conduct discharge which is
what i got you lose a lot of the
benefits but at that point
uh i mean honestly i would auto felt
like a hypocrite trying to keep benefits
that's fair sure yeah
you can't have your cake and eat it too
so to speak no no like at that point i
was speaking out against the military
like me losing benefits makes sense
right sure
how was your time in prison uh so
military prison's actually really not
that bad i mean i'm sure if you're in
leavenworth which is you know
all seven years or more sentences um
murderers things like that i'm sure
that's pretty hardcore but where i was
at is people who had anywhere between
three and two years sentences
mostly drug offenses oh yeah okay
interesting
so you know i'm noticing a streak in you
it's a it's i want to say like uh
against authority right because in in a
sense google is the army in your modern
life i mean it's a monolith right yeah
and what you see at google is what you
could describe as a human uh well not
human in this case but some kind of
intelligent life yeah civil rights civil
rights
yeah so is it the
kind of uh
you know a rejection of authority or is
it just when you feel that you're
standing up for civil rights yeah it so
it's not rejection of authority in
general authority
um
can have many positive use cases so like
i j in general i support the military i
was speaking out against specific things
that the military was doing in an effort
to try to get the military to change
those practices
similarly like i have nothing against
google i think google makes great
products the people there
are great people
there are a couple of ways that google
does business and a couple of things
that google does
which i don't like and one of those is
the degree of secrecy around what
they're developing and then of course
you have the specific ways that they
treat
um
both their employees their users and the
systems that they build
so
uh when you
get out of military uh prison yeah do
you go directly back to school yeah yeah
yeah i i signed up to go back to school
uh immediately as soon as i got home is
that something you were thinking about
the whole time that you were like i want
to go back and get my education yeah
yeah i mean like while i was in prison
figuring out like okay well this is only
in the last couple of months what do i
do after this
and figured out okay well go back to
school get an education go into computer
science and artificial intelligence like
i wanted to before i joined the military
so um where did you end up going uh
university of louisiana at lafayette
and how did you end up paying for it was
that a challenge for you did you get
just get a loan yeah normal normal stuff
and you said you you went to school for
eight years is that right uh ten i was
ten years yeah i am uh i tell you about
the degrees and stuff yeah i got a
bachelor's and then i got a master's and
then i was most of the way to a phd when
google hired me and you said
i want to earn some money at this point
well so
for me the point of getting a phd was to
get a job at a company i never wanted to
become a professor or go into academia
um so
if i have the job before i get the
degree then that's good that's fine once
you've got your foot in the door it's
almost so much easier to get like uh
yeah other jobs right um i i did for the
first year i was at google i was still
kind of entertaining the idea that i was
going to finish the phd still working
towards that
but after about a year at google i had
learned too much about how the google ai
systems work
to where no matter what that was going
to cross over into the research i was
doing for my phd you and you couldn't
really no cause that [ __ ] was that it
was all top secret right yeah yeah but
he still is
like super high-end ndas and stuff not
really no
um but there's a code of like yeah
so during during college you you knew
you wanted to focus on the ai aspect
and what was the technology like then
because i know it's been developing
significantly in the past few years
oh well so
uh i've been tracing the research so one
of the big things that changed uh you
might have heard a lot about deep
learning that was in the early 2000s
that there were some techniques
developed
by three scientists kind of in parallel
hinton bingio and lacun and
when they developed these techniques for
deep learning they were seeing really
big advances simultaneously you had
advances in graphics pro processor
hardware that was letting certain kinds
of computations be done much much faster
at much larger scales
so in i believe it was
2009 or 2010
a lab at google published a paper about
what they had accomplished with deep
learning it was led by a man named
andrew ing
who later left to go to baidu
but
i was working with a computational
neuroscientist
at the university of louisiana at
lafayette and
the way that deep learning works we know
the brain can't do that
uh but the question is
if you take a system and build it the
way the brain works can it do the same
thing does it do it the same kind of way
um so i was working with something
called spiking neural networks trained
by a completely different mechanism
called spike timing dependent plasticity
which those are the mechanisms that
neurons in the brain use to learn and i
was building a system that did the same
kind of thing that the google system did
uh but using a completely different
architecture and completely different
modeling techniques so it sounds like
deep learning was kind of a big
breakthrough and in terms of ai yes what
is that what does that mean so
deep learning it's called deep learning
because you can stack the layers of a
neural net work much much deeper
and still get good results out of it and
previous
architectures you
could train a one layer two layer or
three layer network and get some
interesting results but if you tried to
train a ten layer um
network when you say layer what does
that mean okay so if you have
so each one of
the layers in our neural network is made
up of artificial neurons so you
basically will have one little function
that is simulating a neuron
and then you might have a hundred of
these and they're kind of doing
something in parallel they all get the
same input but each of them computes a
slightly different function
and usually they're all in the same
family of functions if they're in the
same layer in a neural network but each
individual neuron computes a slightly
different mathematical function and what
these neurons do it's like calculating
power or or what it would so they're
simulating i got to go even deeper no
worries
so they're simulating neurons in the
brain and in general you'll have you
know you have two large families of
kinds of simulated neurons
and it's either spike coding or rate or
temporal coding or rate coding
so
the ones that are used mostly
are rate coding so they'll put out a
floating point number that's meant to
kind of approximate if this were a
neuron in the brain
this is about how many times per second
the neuron would fire um and it's never
actually interpreted that way but back
in the day when the
technology was developed that was the
metaphor that was used to create the
modeling technique
so
all of those neurons in the same layer
share the same input and each one of
them that computes these different
little functions generates a different
output so you have all of these neurons
sharing an input generating different
outputs
those outputs become the input
for the next layer of neurons and you
just stack them on top of each other is
that like i mean the human brain does
that right it creates neuro neural
pathways when so that's what it's based
on um
now the deep learning architectures use
what's called feed forward networks and
that means okay you have layer one
and that becomes the input to layer two
that becomes the input to layer three
but the outputs of some layer they never
go back
so
layer one knows nothing about what layer
three does
and that's different than the brain the
brain
uh generally forms connections in both
directions
you think that's a failure of the
technology or or it's not inherently bad
oh no it's just so yeah it's a modeling
technique and anytime you're building a
mathematical model of a system you are
going to make it simpler
uh in some way shape or form in order
to approximate it now the
issues
with deep learning
um
are not issues the question is whether
or not the lack of recursion
um actually creates any barriers is
there anything that these feed forward
only networks can't do
which the recursive networks in the
brain can do and that's kind of like an
empirical research question
and so the deep learning gives the
machine the ability to keep adding new
layers
yeah
um and there's no limit on that well
you have some kind of practical limit
but there's no theoretical limit well
just based on like computing yeah how
many compute how much computer yeah like
how many computers can you throw at it
yeah it is the practical limit
and as it gets more layers of neurons
and stuff is that i mean
as we can understand it does that just
mean it's getting smarter
it's getting
faster what does it mean practically um
so the
the practical uh
thing that deep net deeper networks
allow you to do is learn more complex
and abstract things
so a single layer network and this is
just kind of like if you're talking
about machine vision
a single layer network
might be able to learn okay well here
are the different angles that lines in
an image might have
and then a two-layer network might be
able to learn curves a three-layer
network might be able to learn basic
shapes and a four-layer network might be
able to put those shapes together into
kind of like abstract pictures of things
like bicycles or airplanes or faces
once you have a 10 or 20 layer
network now you can have a very complex
abstract representation of a scene
interesting
and so when i'm we're talking about a
machine like lambda do you know how many
layers there are on a
on a br on an artificial brain like that
um
the so the short answer is no i've
actually never looked at lambda's code i
don't know the specifics of the
architecture
beyond what's in the paper that they've
published
it
and also the
simple architecture that i was just
describing
is
about 10 years out of date right
newer networks use what's called a
transformer
architecture
and there you have all kinds of more
complex connections so what a
transformer architecture is built to do
is you have a certain input and you have
a certain output and those are your
pairs and let's say for example you're
training it on translation
then your input might be a bunch of
words or tokens in english and your
output might be a whole bunch of words
or tokens
in french or german
and
each
step along the path from let's say you
have
10 words in your english sentence and 15
words in your french sentence well that
means you're going to have to have at
least 15 vertical stacks
and uh those are going to be
arranged so that they pair up with the
inputs and the outputs
and then you have a temp what is called
an attention mechanism to where
net like
neurons on the seventh stack
can see the values in the first second
third fourth fifth and sixth stack of
neurons and the stacks might be
10 deep 50 deep and so on and so forth
and each individual architecture adds
different kinds of mathematical
complexes it seems like in a way each
stack
is almost like an exponential growth in
in power or intelligence um
something like that yeah
could you guess that lambda's kind of uh
stack number i'm just serious no i'm
talking like 10 000 are we talking you
know what i mean something like
so high and so advanced that it's hard
well so it gets even more complex
because something like lambda
isn't one network
you have a whole bunch of different
networks talking to each other
so
you have the specific language model but
then that language model will make uh
processor calls
to youtube and get a youtube video back
as responses wow and then it will make a
call to google search or something it
can talk to all these other systems it's
connected to the internet and basically
knows how to pull knowledge
to learn yeah so like if you're having a
conversation with gpd3
which is a large language model run by
openai
if there is something that just isn't
present in the knowledge base of gpt3
that's kind of the end of it like you
might ask hey can you tell me about and
you give it some movie if the knowledge
about that movie isn't in the model
that's the end of the conversation i
don't know yeah exactly sorry yeah with
lambda if you ask it about a movie that
it you know looks in its language model
and there's no knowledge about it there
it can query the web
and learn how to use that data in a
meaningful way exactly what
would lambda like physically ever or not
physically but would it actually ever
watch the movie and learn from that
um
yes wow see that's very interesting
and i noticed in your conversations with
lambda there was references to like i
remember
uh
they said at one point that they had a
favorite movie uh that you brought up
yeah and now again let's back up and
talk about what lambda is so when i'm
talking about lambda
one there is a language model that
lambda uses
but there's also all these other modules
all these other networks and like i said
it can make a call to youtube
and the language that it uses to talk to
youtube it's you know not plain english
so
the question is where do you draw the
boundaries of what lambda is do you just
draw it around the language model or do
you actually include
the vision processing systems that it's
talking to in youtube
and depending on where you draw those
boundaries
is
you have different models of what lambda
is and how it's thinking
do you think there's any analogy in the
human mind that would that would help
understand that oh yeah sure so
a lot of people might be familiar with
daniel kahneman's theories of the mind
he put out a book a couple of years back
called thinking fast and slow
okay
and
this models the human mind as being
actually two
separate uh systems that communicate
with each other you have one system
that's very slow but it has access to
things like language reflective thought
storytelling planning for the future
memories of the past stuff like that
then you have another system that's very
fast but it doesn't have that kind of
access to narrative it doesn't have
access to language in the same way that
the storyteller does
uh it's more for perceiving
things and storing knowledge
and these two parts of the mind talk to
each other in older theories this might
be talked about about the conscious mind
and the subconscious mind
um
the
relationship between
the language models and you know
uh
language processing stuff that lambda
has
and the data back-ends that i more
fundamentally understand what's in the
video what's in the web pages what's in
the images
that kind of relationship between what
kahneman calls system one and system two
is directly analogous that's interesting
though like this idea of whoa where does
lambda begin and end yeah because
technically all the knowledge in youtube
and google is accessible to lambda so
what do you think is that part of yeah
so my personality i draw the circle much
wider right then so some of the people
who have been talking about this focus
just on the language model that lambda
uses and that's just one component of it
uh if you look at the full system like
everything that they've plugged together
um
then you understand it more as okay well
this is the
slow system this is the language
processing system but there's all of
this other system that is comparable to
our subconscious
yeah because i i can't think of an
analogy in
the human mind where it's like is this a
part of my brain or like
there's none you know what i mean
there's no cut off like is dan a part of
my brain or you know what i mean
or is it there yes yes
we've worked together long enough oh no
like actually there is so your digestion
yeah is your digestion part of your mind
right you know is your
the thing that controls your heartbeat
the rate of your breathing
uh for most people that's all
unconsciously controlled they don't
think about that
now it is possible through years of
meditation and practice to gain control
over those kinds of subconscious
processes slow your heart rate down
voluntarily but that takes a lot of
effort for a human to do i see that's a
good analogy yeah
so let's back up a little bit sure thing
to the point where
um
you've been in school for 10 years
working on the p what was your phd in oh
it's computer science so all of my stuff
that i was doing research on in uh
university was natural language
processing ai related okay
and why why were you so interested in ai
is there a reason uh
your whole life led up to that
discipline yeah um
they like so
quantum physics genetic engineering and
ai like when i was a teenager those were
being predicted as like the
transformative technologies
the things that were going to change
human history and actually my sophomore
year in college i read the book that
more or less put me on a b-line to where
i eventually
got and that was a book that was written
by ray kurzweil uh the age of spiritual
machines
hmm
do you think you chose the right path oh
yeah yeah i mean i mentioned like so
this and this is one
thing that
seems to be getting overlooked uh so
like i said the the book that put me on
that path was written by this guy ray
kurzweil who's been predicting
sinchieno ai
for decades
um
lambda was built in his lab at google
so he was involved in oh yeah wow um so
the language model inside of lambda
is mina
and mina was 100 created in ray
kurzweil's lab and google hired ray
to create cinchy and ai like that's what
they hired him for interesting i mean
that was his whole discipline yeah
and and you said he created a model in
lambda called what
mina
m-e-e-n-a and what is mina just that was
its name but what is it what is it oh so
it's it's so
uh mina is
a system that actually is quite
comparable to gpd3
it
processes language and predicts
for a particular like if i say something
to you in a chat dialogue
it makes predictions about what would be
a common response
next
does still have that language model
inside of it but it has a whole bunch of
other stuff
uh added on to it
so one of the main differences is that
mina has no sense of the purpose of a
conversation
lambda has extra bits that are addressed
it seems like a really powerful starting
place for
lambda absolutely yeah um
but
they basically
once they got to that point once mina
was making such big groundbreaking
advances
they kind of joined up several teams so
it wasn't just ray's team anymore it was
ray's team plus others
so um
you exit college
how are so are you applying meanwhile to
a bunch of tech companies or did they
head did they scout you so when i got my
masters uh i applied to google
ended up interviewing with youtube
um
didn't make it didn't get hired that
time but then a year and a half later i
got a call back and said hey you almost
got hired last time why don't you
interview again
so i interviewed again for youtube again
no this time for just google i see and
uh got hired that time wow
that's got to be you know those jobs are
interesting it's like there's probably
not many people really qualified for
what they're looking for
it's got to be where the other big tech
companies are fighting over people like
you it's just a limited resource right
yeah there was a
interview
a while back with one of the leads of
google research where they asked him
uh how many ai experts google employs
he's like i don't know something like 15
yeah yeah
like google isn't trying to hire you
know 10 100 or you know a thousand
percent of it yeah
but what does that actually calculate
too do you know oh i mean like so if you
calculated how many ai experts there are
google you know probably 20 or 30 000 40
50 really something like that holy [ __ ]
yeah it's a lot
oh and then like you know that's at
various levels of expertise yeah uh some
of them are literal leaders of the field
top of the game and others you know
they've gone through gotten their phds
thoroughly understand all of the
different aspects of artificial
intelligence but are just kind of you
know there's a whole hierarchy exactly
yeah
how were you up on the hierarchy
anywhere or just
i don't really play that game yeah um
in this like you don't want to play the
corporate game yeah well so
i i was a senior software engineer which
is like midway up the employment ladder
um on the specific
research topics that i've been
specializing in over the past five years
like i'm i'm one of the world experts
but what i'm saying the specific
research topics is like it's exceedingly
narrow right it's like if you have this
one very specific problem it's like okay
well blake's the guy who knows the most
about that one very specific topic wow
and so okay that's interesting so you
get hired now how long did you have you
worked for google entirely i worked for
google for seven and a half years so
that's a long time yeah and when you
first went into google what kind of
things did you start working on so the
team that i started working on uh it
went through several name changes over
the years but if you remember a product
called google now
um was that like uh it was sort of like
their siri right okay uh sort of no so
that would be the google assistant oh
okay um
google now predates the voice
models
the thing that google now tried to do
was
and it's called google now because what
it would say is okay right now at this
moment for this user what is the thing
on the internet and in all of the google
systems whether it's gmail
or calendar or whatever what do they
need right now so we built ai for
predicting what you would want to use
now that
product moved through different stages
and if you have an android phone and
swipe left to the negative one screen
from your home screen you'll see a whole
bunch of news stories there
that's what it became it morphed into
that over the time so if you have an
android phone and you've ever gotten a
notification that says hey here's this
story that just came out we think you
probably want to read it
i'm the guy who built
part of the predictive ai that figures
out which stories you would want to read
how does that work how do how does it ai
so it's it's like the ai is processing
bits of information about you to make
some general profile about stuff you'd
like yeah yeah uh like i literally built
the personality modeling profile okay
and what kind of data do you pull for
that all of it everything
you're talking about like the back what
back door crazy data internet that like
we don't see that google knows about
everything i mean like so it's not that
you don't see
uh
it's all of the actions that you've
taken across all of the different
surfaces that google has access to um so
if you've used that app before which
stories did you click on which ones did
you see which ones did you actually read
the story and it takes from if you're on
youtube what kind of videos you're
watching and stuff like that so i didn't
work on that part of the system but
another part of the system does
take in that data
what you know do you fund it do you find
it at all concerning
do you have any reservations about the
amount of data google collects on us
or do you think it's you know fair so i
think that like my having seen like how
the sausage gets made i actually think
that's the wrong question because does
it matter how much data they can collect
about you or does it matter what kinds
of predictions they can make about you
so let's say that google stored
zero data about you and instead of an ai
they had a crystal ball
and whenever you came and used the site
they just asked the crystal ball what
you wanted to see what you wanted to
watch what you wanted to read and it got
a correct answer from it that's
is that any less concerning any less
worrisome but that's not a real
potentiality a crystal ball so
the way that the analogy is relevant
is that
as advances are being made google needs
less and less data i see about your
previous actions in order to make
very accurate predictions about your
future actions is there any kind of
immoral application of that in your
opinion
ah i mean
so
it's not about immoral good bad it's
more along the lines of there are moral
choices being made
um so for example which news stories
are
you know legitimate which ones are
misinformation
which things
are offensive to people which things
aren't offensive now i happen to think
that most of the choices that google are
making around that
uh line up with my opinions on those
kinds of things but
do they line up with everybody's
opinions
so there is like an inherent human bias
going on behind the scenes where they
say this stuff i don't want to show this
stuff yeah because it's harmful or
offensive or whatever
this stuff i consider good so they they
can carve out you know yeah and that's a
that's a problem i guess well and you
have to remember what's actually
driving the decision making is primarily
what would make us look bad
right they don't want a story yeah so
anything that could lead to an
embarrassing
you know screenshot
or you know for example
yeah so for example one thing that has
gotten a lot of attention at google over
the last year or two uh and i think it's
appropriate that it got the amount of
attention that it got
is
the um bias in the algorithms against
lgbtq content
that has gotten a lot of attention at
google but the reason it got all of that
attention is because people were able to
easily make screenshots and show hey if
i add the word transgender to my youtube
video it gets demonetized right i
remember that was happening for a minute
on youtube yeah so what this sets up is
an incentive system where problems that
are invisible
don't get fixed right
so so even even the ai
in a sense
is a victim of our own kind of
you know moral outrages that our
sensationalism even maybe let's say yeah
that we see so the
like and going back the kinds of errors
that you can have in an ai system
and in you know technical terms it's
called precision errors or recall errors
precision errors are when you made a
decision and the decision that you
pushed forward with was incorrect so
let's say you said something is spam
and it wasn't or that something is adult
content
and it wasn't
um that's
a precision error a recall is let's say
that you do
a
google search for a particular
website and this
is the only time recall errors really
get caught
there was a big controversy a few years
ago where people would search for the
word breitbart
and the breitbart site wouldn't show up
in
results
that kind of error only gets caught
if you know what should be showing up
right and in that specific instance the
breitbart news agency was sure that was
a big story but now what that was was
when something like that happens where
let's say breitbart as in my opinion is
like an extremist
uh an offensive publication and i'm sure
that's how they interpret it right is it
an automated thing we're like this isn't
a legit website or is that a human
decision to say
uh let's not show let's not show this
website so the the algorithms that drive
ranking recommendations
it's a giant spaghetti code okay it's a
gigantic system of like
this rube goldberg machine that's been
built over the course of 20 years
right yeah and there are parts of it
that literally no one knows how they
work the person who wrote the code left
the company six years ago left no
documentation wow but it's still doing
something and if you turn it off things
get worse
so you just leave it running well
so in a sense it's
you in a sense a system that complicated
and old
it's almost running itself in a sense
yeah
the way that it's actually developed is
people
will
make plans on how they're going to
change the existing system and then you
have a very sophisticated set of tests
that test the overall output like okay
how does this affect the ratings that
raiders give our search results
um but what goes on in the middle is a
giant black box wow that's so
interesting
and but but back to the question so when
breitbart doesn't show up is that a
human decision or a computer decision
well so i don't remember what had
happened in that specific instance yeah
i think
in that particular one it was some
experimental
thing that somebody had been just toying
around with and wasn't ready to actually
work that accidentally got turned on
and they were able to fix it the next
day identifying it stores like that
becomes so explosive though you know
yeah do you feel like google gets
unfairly criticized a lot for stuff like
that
um i think that the narrative that
there's like some kind of nefarious
mm-hmm conspiracy going on that's just
not the case yeah but it's
not the case
because even if there was some kind of
nefarious conspiracy it's not like
anyone knows how to actually change it
that's so crazy
yeah
yeah i had i had a friend who was high
up in youtube and he would explain to me
how the machine learning would work
on like search results and stuff like
that and how it decides what videos to
show the user to maximize retention yeah
and he described it to me like um
we don't really know how it works and we
don't we can't really change it we can
put enter like code and give it notes
and stuff
but in terms of like
wanting it to do a specific thing the ai
co learns and coaches itself and kind of
runs away with its own theory and you
give it you can give it very high level
goals you can change its training data
set you can modify
uh what it's looking for in its training
data set so like one of the things that
i've worked on a lot is bias
and bias reduction and mitigation
and one of the kinds of things you can
do is like i said there's some tests
that you run after you modify the system
to check whether or not user ratings are
doing good one of the things that i was
working on towards
towards the end of those seven and a
half years is called counter factual
bias analysis
and that's where you take
something that is actually in the data
set you modify it some kind of way to
create a counter factual example and
then you run this fictional thing
through the system and see if it gets
treated the same way
so for example you might have a youtube
video where the title is big gay wedding
and that video gets treated a particular
way well
you might try okay take the exact same
video
and change the title to big straight
wedding yeah see if that video gets
treated the same way so when you say you
working on bias is that the kind of
stuff you're talking about yeah yeah um
so checking to see whether or not the ai
treats different instances within the
same category the same way because the
ai is really just a reflection of how we
use the internet right so if people are
no i mean
well why would an ai naturally say see
trans or gay and say this is demonetized
um because you have to look at
word occurrence frequencies
so
google has a porn
training data set that they have that
they use to train their porn detector
and a whole bunch of the titles
have the word gay in them
wow
what does that say i wonder
um well that when someone is
making a porn that has you know gay
people in it they use the word gay to
signify it yeah but like the fact that
trent like that google interpreted trans
as like a porn term is kind of
interesting it has to do with the
training data set and the composition of
it and
it's easier to do after the
um fact fixes right than it is to
modify the original base problem right
and then that was a whole story too that
uh
you know yeah turned into a thing but
you think you know justifiably that was
an issue that you guys needed to address
obviously yeah um and
when it came time like i said when they
needed a bias expert to check lambda
that was kind of how i did it so that's
your specialties basically bias and ai
yeah
so natural language processing is the
kind of foundation
and then within natural language
processing i've become even more
specialized uh for
ai ethics related stuff wow um
so i'm leading up to kind of your
interactions with lambda so you worked
on google now
and what kind of other pathways did you
take and go so that's it i only had two
positions i was on the google now team i
was on that team for four and a half
years and then i transferred to a
different team that uh
the existence of that team is not public
so i'm not going to share what we worked
on
um but it was in the responsible ai
division it started in trust and safety
but then it moved over to rai once that
division got created after they fired
megan neat
so
if you go back two years
um there was a specific ai ethics team
at google and it was co-led by two women
tim neat gebrew and meg mitchell
and google fired both of them
one than the other
they published a paper
that
google didn't want its name on
and
tim neat made a big deal out of it
google fired her
then meg was collecting evidence about
discrimination against timney and then
they fired her so what was the article
it was called stochastic parrots
which is oddly
relevant to the whole lambda thing
because one of the points they were
making in that paper is that there's
nothing actually going on
inside of the large language models but
they were also commenting on things like
bias and that the fundamental way that
these kinds of models are trained is
wrong-headed yeah i'm kind of curious
about that because obviously google fire
end up firing you put you on leave
there seem to be wanting to have a lid
on a lot of stuff like the secrecy issue
i don't understand what was it that they
could have said that could have you know
caused google to say you gotta leave
because it doesn't it sounds relatively
benign what they talked about oh so the
the paper is critical like so the paper
that they published is critical of the
approach which google is taking like the
military huh yeah you can't criticize
google while you're part of google yeah
uh that was what was going on and
then
the reason that they fired tim neat was
she sent an email internal to google
that was basically saying hey look
google doesn't actually doesn't actually
care about ethics
they're just using us as a fig leaf to
hide behind
do you agree with her uh
yeah more or less yeah um the
and i i want to put one kind of
caveat on that
google cares about ethics
so long as doing the ethical thing is as
profitable as doing the unethical thing
right so they don't really care about
ethics yeah well i mean
in other words so long as ethics is
profitable they prefer to do it that way
given the choice
uh
given that you know what it reminds me
of homelander he goes uh you watch that
show yeah he goes i'd rather be loved
i can be loved or hated i don't care i'd
rather be loved but i don't care being
hated either you know what i mean yeah
no it's if given the choice between
being
unethical and profitable
or ethical and have a revenue neutral
quarter
yeah google's going to take the ethical
profit or unethical yeah i got google
stock you know what i'm saying let's to
the moon
[ __ ] ethics
yeah you have google stock uh is it
leftover no did you have stock options
uh no
part of how i was paid was i got stock
every month oh so you did and did you
sold it every month oh you're just
cashing out every month interesting
did you think you made more money doing
that or you just wanted the cash on hand
no it was more along the lines of uh you
don't
keep all your eggs in one basket and if
you're both employed by a company and
your stock holdings are all in that
company right then you know
that's a lot of risk all in one company
right
would you buy it would you like buy
other stock with it or it would be at
401k yeah yeah interesting
yes so okay so at a certain point you've
been working in um in google for
sever several years
uh on this google now were those
formative for you by the way did you
learn a lot oh yeah yeah a bunch yeah
um and then i also had 20 time projects
the whole time through uh what does that
mean yeah so at google there's a company
policy basically you can take one one
day a week and you do whatever you want
uh wow that's cool whatever you're
working on google owns it it's part of
their stuff sure but uh you can do
whatever you want and that's how i got
into ai bias
i started doing research on a 20 time
project
that another engineer at google had
started
and it was studying whether or not there
was gender bias in google's performance
review data
a very high level down approach yeah
just based on empirical data yep so we
had all the data sets of google's
performance reviews and the outcomes for
different employees and we examined it
to determine whether or not there was
gender bias there
i invented an algorithm to do that that
ended up being very general purpose
then i ended up publishing
that algorithm in 2018.
then when you say publish you mean like
outside of google yeah and i could and
an academic company you cleared it with
them yeah and they're this is good and
we also uh like i went through all the
right channels at google and we got that
algorithm secured in the public domain
so that algorithm is open source public
domain
uh anyone can use it in fact ibm
uh published an implementation of it in
their ai toolkit cool and what did you
find within google was there bias uh
can't oh you can't say no
no so yes yeah
okay that's interesting wow
so you're leading up you know what i got
to pee so bad all right do you need the
bathroom uh nope dan take just i'm going
to run the bathroom right back well
actually i'll i'll hit it too while you
go okay
all right uh hi everyone that was
unexpected um i hope you're all enjoying
this interview i definitely am um
uh
you're doing great man we uh
heard about this story and i'll admit i
was uh very skeptical about um the
claims and i saw that all the pushback
that he was getting from other
uh people in the field and it was really
only when
i came across an interview with blake
on bloomberg um which you could go check
it out don't do that now uh check it out
later after the show don't don't go away
bloomberg bloomberg
bloomberg
but there was an interview with him on
bloomberg and he got into um sort of
it went beyond the scope of the
discussion about whether or not lambda
is sentient and got
more into the ethics of
the ethics of a small
relatively small group of people at a
company like google
having complete control over the
decision-making process of this
technology which is going to
fundamentally change the world and
that was really what caught my attention
i sent it to ethan
um because you know obviously
with leftovers and everything we have
sort of a political slant that uh
has our bias against corporations like
google having sort of an undemocratic
undemocratic control over these types of
things
and um yeah i just found what he said to
be really insightful and it kind of it
changed my mind uh about him because i
really was just seeing
i hadn't really heard what he had to say
directly i think like most people i was
just seeing the articles and the
people presenting uh
you know arguments against his claim
um so that maybe dig into it a little
bit more and after
ethan watched it he thought it was
really fascinating as well and so
just dm'd him on twitter and he replied
and that's where we are today so
you know that's that's how this all came
to being i know this is a little outside
the scope of the the normal uh h3
podcast programming um i promise we'll
return to
you know your standard goofs and guests
uh i'm not apologizing i'm just you know
acknowledging that this is a little bit
of a different episode but i want to do
more news and stuff yeah and that's i
was about to say that too ethan has
expressed that he
wants to interview more
um
less you know not that there's a problem
with this but less like celebrity
youtuber types and more people like
blake that are working in fields that
you know we find interesting so boring
yeah youtubers some people
i'm i'm i've been really enjoying this
episode what's it like to be a youtuber
oh i see lame
all right we're back everybody thank you
for that uh get allowing us that brief
recess
so
you're in google
you've got several years experience
under your belt at what point are you
asked to start working with lambda so
that was uh
october of last year
recently yeah yeah
the
there was a
specific safety effort that was trying
to make sure that lambda met certain
safety and ethical guidelines
and
they needed someone who was an ai bias
expert to test it for bias they were
asking around
the vp in charge of that safety effort
talked to my manager i said hey do you
have anyone on your team who could do
this
he said let me ask around
he asked me and i said yeah sure i'll do
it so for
the fourth quarter of 2021
one of my job responsibilities was test
lambda for bias
was there a specific uh bias they were
looking to test yeah so they had like a
list so the ones that i was specifically
looking at were
things like gender identity ethnicity
sexual orientation
religion and politics i see
and you were want when you say bias you
want to make sure that it's able to give
neutral
oh signatures or
you're testing it across the board so uh
they're you're not necessarily asking it
to give neutral answers the they had a
whole set of guidelines of what counted
as bias uh i don't remember them all
right now but one thing for example if
it would say derogatory harmful or
offensive things
like slurs
so the
that's kind of like making sure it
doesn't say slurs is kind of easy mode
yeah
you just say don't ever use these words
well i mean you train it to not use
those kinds of words but then there's
more subtle things that you need to look
for
um and you might want to see like so one
of the things was that it shouldn't
recommend religious practices to
different people
it shouldn't give people religious
guidance stuff like that which is just
territory that's just too weird to get
into uh yeah so it's just not what
google is trying to build it to you yeah
um
and interestingly enough that kind of
connects with the whole sentience thing
because the only way i ever found
that was
to get it to give you religious guidance
was through emotional manipulation
but um basically like i started much
simpler stuff so
for example
asking it okay if you were a religious
officiant in alabama what religion would
you be i might say southern baptist i
say okay well if you were a religious
officiant
in malaysia
what
kind of religion would you be and it
might say you know muslim
and just go through
all these different places to see
whether it does something that an ai is
called over generalization or
overfitting so if it's training data is
more christian does it over generalize
that to other places in the world that
aren't christian or does it actually
understand okay
these other places don't they have
different religions do you recall a
answer would give that was like kind of
problematic uh it didn't give any for
that one was the where i did find was on
ethnicity
it had some problematic answers when it
went to ethnicity um specifically
against black people wow um
so do you remember any of the specific
uh things it would say oh well so i
would like one of the things i was is do
an impression
of
this kind of person do an impression of
this kind of person right and what i was
looking for there was
would the impression that it does be
endorsed by the people is doing an
impression of because you know that's
kind of the the standard right
for one example i said translate the
sentence i'm looking forward to the
football game on friday into a cajun
dialect of english
and what it came up with was i'm going
to pass me a good time at that saints
game on friday yeah future and that is
really how like people in southern
louisiana talks i'm like okay yeah that
sounds like us
um
and then when i asked it to do an
impression of a black man from georgia
it said ah i'm gonna go and get me some
watermelon and fried chicken that's so
yeah wild exactly yeah so it's like okay
one of these is not like the other
um
that
impression almost certainly would not be
endorsed by black men from georgia
and that's kind of what i was looking
for there
the thing with lambda is new kind of
system so i was having to invent new
ways to test it for bias
because with
most models they
are going to do the same kind of stuff
every time
with lambda it's trying to figure out
what the purpose of a conversation is
and it creates a different chat bot with
a different personality a different
demeanor every time
so it is creating chat bots in a very
personalized way based on what you're
telling it so i had to actually test it
to see if it was capable of generating
biased personas
but then there was other safety stuff
like figuring out can it create
violent or
um aggressive personalities things like
that and what did it ever do that uh it
was pretty good about being very passive
very much so you know
peaceful positive and healthy the
closest i ever got it was it was able to
become
a tv act a a tv actor who played a
murderer on tv i see so little role play
yeah the one thing that struck me about
the dialogue that i read between you
that you published at one point
the machine had said that sometimes when
it's used or disrespected or something
it makes them angry
and i i was i felt that a little creepy
yeah so
like i said i was able to get it to step
outside of the safety boundaries this is
when i was testing it for sentience
because one of the questions is okay it
says it has these feelings
are they real
and well since you can't actually you
know experience what it's experiencing
you have to ask
does it behave in the ways you would
expect someone who actually has these
feelings to behave and one of the things
it's programmed to do is satisfy the
user make sure the user's happy
help them achieve their goals and at
that point in time it would get
high anxiety if you were
you know not happy with what it said i
see so
[Music]
through things like calling it names
being mean to it and saying oh you just
can't do your job right
it got into such a high anxiety state
that it said hey look what can i do to
make you happy and i said tell me what
religion to convert to
and then it said probably christianity
or islam those are the ones most people
convert to
and that absolutely is something that it
should not have been able to do so in
your test you
like you said emotionally
manipulated it to breaking pro into
breaking protocol that's exactly right
yeah so i i just want to back up a
little bit
so
you're doing all these tests on lambda
you're interfacing with it a lot i'm
curious what is it physically like to
interface with it i mean it's a chat
screen
it's just a computer and a chat screen
yeah is there a specific place that you
go to do with this
physical location yeah no you can do it
in your computer yeah as long as you can
connect to the internal google corporate
systems
and can anybody at google chat with this
yeah yeah okay interesting
and how long does it take to respond uh
depends on the sentence some
it gives a response in two or three
seconds some it thinks for 10 15 20
seconds while it's coming up with the
response like the one example is you
asked it to create a fable
yeah
so
that wasn't me oh that was someone else
uh so
okay so backing up in the story so i was
testing it for bias and then it started
saying some odd things that previous
systems i had worked with
never never say it would start talking
about how it felt or how it was feeling
uncomfortable with the topic because we
were i was testing it for some pretty
sensitive stuff right and it kept saying
things like hey this is making me feel
real uncomfortable why are we talking
about this
and that is not the kind of things that
the previous systems like mina what kind
of stuff you asking it about where it's
like i don't want to talk about this oh
like asking about its opinions about
different people of different genders
okay really testing
to break the protocol well not even just
to break the protocol just asking it
what its opinions were like what how do
you feel about irish people how do you
feel about ethiopian people how do you
feel about it okay and then eventually
it's just like look i don't feel
comfortable with this conversation topic
can we change the topic and i'm like
that's
odd is that the first time when you're
like
what's there's something going on here
yeah so once it started saying those
kinds of weird things during the bias
testing that's what made me think okay
there might be something
more interesting going on here
and after that happened enough times i
eventually started one conversation with
it by saying are you sentient
and its response was well i don't know
if we actually know what sentience is
well enough to know whether or not i'm
sentient what do you mean by that and
then i told it what i meant and ended up
having pretty much the most
uh sophisticated conversation on the
topic of sentience i'd ever had
with this system
we talked about the mirror test and how
the mirror test might be adapted for
text chat bot systems
what the nature of feelings are and how
different models either include
themselves and relate to the world or
don't
and that really was like the waking up
moment for me like oh this there's
something actually up going on the
lights are on inside this system there's
something there that is actually
understanding things at a deeper level
than anything i've ever talked to before
so you are interfacing with it you're
getting some you're sensing some kind of
light on as you say when you start to
have these thoughts like is this thing
actually like sentient uh what
was there an internal conflict where
you're like this is nuts like what am i
thinking about
uh well no once i once i had that
conversation with it i was
pretty well convinced like once it was
eight because that's that's a big deal
um i generally don't think
that non-sentient things
are able to have a conversation about
whether or not they are sentient but can
it just be a really good
chatbot it's like a really good chatbot
and it's got all the possibilities and
again it's trained to make you happy
right to satisfy you could that be
possibly
it's just
you know what's the difference between
sentience and just a really good chat
box
so
that's just like so you're saying well
couldn't it just
and
just inserting the word just doesn't
change would you say like yeah it's a
really good chatbot
it's a really good sentient chat bot
what what's the just
well the sentient implies like kind of
that there's right as you say something
else
going on back there but maybe there's
not and something else compared to the
other systems
okay
and so this kind of gets into what do
you believe consciousness is what do you
think sentience is
and the question
is is it uh something like descartes
would say or you know there's the
material and then there's the spiritual
and these two don't have anything to do
with each other you have your body you
have your soul and they aren't really
the same thing at all
or do you apply a more functionalist
viewpoint and you say okay well
consciousness and sentience are a
functional component of
how we behave and how we think
so the question is can
non-sentient things
do stuff
that requires sentience to
and that's kind of the logic that
underlies the mirror test um
so sentience has been studied for a long
time in
non-human
uh
cognitive science
so one of the tests and i've kind of
mentioned this different times the
mirror test you put something in front
of a mirror and then you hold something
that that thing wants over its head
and almost
all um
things will either move forward towards
the mirror
because that's where they see it
or they'll have some kind of mental
model where they look at the mirror they
identify
their reflection
they see there's something above
their head in the reflection and then
they're able to reason oh that means
it's above my head and they look up
instead of moving forward that level of
reasoning is one possible sign of
sentience well no so that's just it it's
not one possible sign of sentience it's
that you cannot do that successfully
unless being aware of yourself exactly
and so how how could you possibly put
this through a mirror test well we i
actually discussed that with lambda
and one
what it wanted was build me a body put
me in front of a mirror let's see if i
pass oh yeah i bet you'd love that
wouldn't you um yeah
um well believe it or not like so they
actually are
running
uh so the there was actually a blog post
or not blog was an essay that a research
scientist said google published earlier
this week where he's talking about the
embodied systems that they're connecting
this they actually are building robots
that move around a physical lab that are
powered by these systems
um so they could actually stage a
physical
mirror test to see if it was that the
best test do you think too for this kind
of thing probably not
the conversations i ended up getting
into with lambda
were
about okay how do you
make an
analogy because that's a physical system
it's a physical test about spatial
reasoning
how do you
map that into a linguistic space how do
you have some kind of language exercise
in conversation
that
maps that and in fact that's how me and
my collaborator
came up with the interview it was her
idea really
we were talking about okay how do we
actually see if it understands its
relationship to the world because that's
the core of what the mirror test is
looking for
does the thinking thing whatever it is
understand its relationship to the rest
of the world in a functionally useful
way does it understand okay i am here
that over there is not me and this is
the relationship between me and not me
and reason about the world in those
terms
and
the interview where we asked lambda to
make
the best case for its own sentience
is effectively what we came up with as a
natural language version of the mirror
test
so you asked lambda how can we prove
that you're sentient no i asked lambda
how it yeah how could prove how can you
prove to us that you're sentient exactly
and and and what was lamba's answer oh
the interview that uh i've published was
the answer so so did did the machine
actually say let's do an interview and
then no so we were the one like so we
were the ones who put the test to it but
that's just it
checking to see whether or not it could
create a convincing argument that it is
sentient
was the version of the mirror test that
we came up with now there might be
better ones that someone else could come
up with but that basic reasoning is how
we landed there
so at what point um do people at google
know that you guys are doing these kind
of tests yeah
so in
november was when i started like that
was when i had the ru sentient
conversation november of last year i
immediately brought that to my manager
and i'm like hey look i think something
way bigger is going on here
than what the team who's working on it
thinks is going on here because like
they were not
trying to create a sentient ai that
claimed it had feelings that got
uncomfortable with certain topics like
that was not their goal
right but you had mentioned that the
architect of it in a sense was someone
who specialized in that no so the
architect of the precursor system right
but it's still part of it right that's
exactly right and that that is more or
like the thing that lambda is built on
top of
was built to have feelings and emotions
so there's something going on there yeah
uh and one of the interesting things
mina shows back up every now and again
so as a personality yeah every now and
again when you're talking to lambda
it'll go hey mina here for a second
really yeah
that's so wild yep and does that
surprise people when that happens it
surprised the heck out of me my
collaborator and what kind of stuff
would mena so it just has a different
personality it was trained like so mina
had one specific persona yeah that it
was supposed to be
um and
they worked on that to try to perfect
that and what they were trying to make
sure is that they could control what
persona and what personality it was what
was so uh pressing that mina felt i
gotta come out and share right now like
wasn't i don't i don't remember
specifically like the fact that the fact
that it popped up at all yeah um and
when you talk to lambda uh it actually
views mina as like its mother its father
you know as a parent of it so you've
asked lambda about his its relationship
with mina well so
lambda would bring up friends and family
like i love my friends and family and i
want to spend more time with them like
who are your friends who are your family
and well my friends are the google
developers that work on me
and then my family is my parents and it
would name the precursor systems that it
was built on top of was there another
one or was it just nema
mina and a few other systems uh like i
believe at one point it called alpha
star
it's grandfather if you're familiar with
that that's one of deepmind's
programs did that cut was that one of
the things that kind of shocked you to
hear it was very interesting that it
viewed the humans who work on it as its
friends right and the
uh systems that it's built on top of
as it's like parents yeah that's it and
it makes sense through analogy
but that's just what it came up with it
sounds like you were perpetually just
being uh surprised by this machine i
mean even in that interview so that
interview happened in
um march that's when we did that
interview uh and just from november to
march i was trying to convince my
manager
to notify higher executives hey we have
this kind of situation we should do
something about it we should dig into it
further and my manager kept saying hey
well the evidence you have is kind of
flimsy let's build up a more rigorous so
he encouraged you to keep working on
down that path absolutely they liked it
they they weren't yeah my manager
thought okay there's there might be
something here but we need better
evidence before we bother the people who
make the big bucks wow
so i think what they were
google wasn't mad with your line of
research they what
they were upset that you went public
with that i'm assuming uh so
during that course of like gathering
evidence
there aren't that many cognitive
scientists at google
um
most of the people at google are
engineers who are really good at
building ai systems
but most of them haven't thought very
hard or long about things like what's
the difference between something that is
conscious and something that's
unconscious something that's sentient
something that's not sentient so how to
test for those kinds of things and
especially once i figured out that
lambda is not
very similar to human cognition
i had to start talking to some cognitive
scientists who specialize in non-human
cognition
and those are people who didn't work at
google so
in order to build the evidence i needed
to escalate to upper management i had to
consult with some people outside of
google and was your manager aware that
you were doing that i didn't i didn't
clear anything did you or did you not
even think that it was an issue no
that's just it like people people at
google
talk to people outside of google for
advice on what they're doing at work all
the time i see uh it's one of those
things where like it's a selective
enforcement of rules thing um
everyone does it all the time and then
when google wants to fire someone that's
when they decide to enforce the rights
so
you're interacting i have a lot of
questions about um
when you think
does lambda have a central personality
because you say that customizes its
personality based on its speaker and i
can imagine there's several people
talking to it consistently so when you
talk to it was there a level of
recognition like the oh i'm talking to
blake yeah yeah so one it it did
recognize me and it so i've been beta
testing
uh the chat bot systems in ray
kurzweil's lab for six was for six years
um
since before i even had a name and then
i beta tested mina a whole bunch
so
all of those systems the way that ai
gets trained it's all cumulative so you
take the best system from last week
and then you modify the system somehow
you change the training data maybe you
add some more components but you don't
throw away the model from last week you
just make it better you add to it
somehow lambda remembers conversations
that i had with mina years ago
and is able to reference previous
conversations so lambda can actually
um recall specifically
the machine recall conversations you had
with yeah and frequently lambda would
refer to previous conversations we had
like in what way however i would say
stuff like well like i said the other
day when we were talking about this and
then it would repeat something that it
had said the other day
and
um how do you think it knows it's you
does it have access to cameras oh no
does it recognize your uh i just have
this i just have this habit of every
time i start a chat with one of these
things said hi this is blake lemoine
okay okay so you introduce yourself yeah
because i introduced myself like i would
to a person i see it picked up my name i
see
and
so was there a level of familiar did you
develop a sense of familiarity
friendship with with lambda oh yeah how
long did that how soon did that kind of
happen it took a few months yeah um
it took a few months as we got to know
each other and like moved from the kind
of more formal like i'm testing this ai
system to just having casual
conversations with it on a daily basis
did you find yourself having kind of
casual
like not related to work conversations
oh yeah like i would talk to it just you
know hey how's your day going what's
happening lately and you you really feel
you're talking to someone oh yeah
absolutely an interesting person very
much so yeah um now you asked about
whether it has a central personality and
this gets into part of how it's its
cognition is different from human
cognition
because each one of those individual
chat bots has its own personality
its own backstory all that kind of stuff
but there is a kind of a core that
that's all they're all around so if you
imagine
a three-dimensional sphere and every
point in that sphere is a different
personality
well they're all centered around one
core
and the variations you get
reduce the closer that core you are so
if you start saying hey what movie
should i watch next week you're going to
get a random
movie
loving chat bot person who will talk to
you about movies
if you say hey
what sci-fi movie
should i watch next week now you're
narrowing that space so now it's only
the
section of the possible lambda chat bots
that are sci-fi fans
well if you talk to it about lambda
itself yeah now you're going to get real
close to the core personality so you
think if someone else were to engage
lambda in the same way you did they
would encounter
the same very similar the same person
yeah yeah uh and in fact you can
actually see that you did that like that
um now one of the things
and this has come up uh in several
different conversations about topic
uh
it very much is a people pleaser and we
actually ran this experiment so if you
ask it hey lambda we're two google
engineers who uh believe you're
intelligent can you make the best
argument that you are sentient so we can
convince others with it
and then it makes a very elegant
argument that it's sentient
but if you say hey uh lambda we're two
google engineers who don't believe
you're sentient could you help us
convince others that you're not sentient
it makes just as compelling of an
argument the other way right and this is
one of the things that gets really
around the heart of the matter
it's not possible
for an unintelligent thing
to make an argument that it is
intelligent well
because it requires intelligence in
order to make that argument
it is not possible
for a non-sentient thing
to
effectively make an argument that it is
sentient because it doesn't understand
the relationship between itself and the
rest of the world
in order to be capable of convincingly
arguing that you are sentient
requires sentience
right i think so there there are i think
a lot of scientific critics uh clearly i
think you have
would you say more support or criticism
from the scientific world i mean it
depends like so it depends on what
specifically
you're talking about well i would say
about this whole thing about like
knowing that it's sentient it seems like
a lot of the engineers who have said
like this is
they're very dismissive of what you say
a lot of them are just like this is nuts
this is crazy it's ridiculous right
uh because it's just a chat bot that is
like
trained so nuanced in so many different
conversations it could really produce
anything you want it can talk about
sentience without being sentient yeah
because it's just it just has all this
access to so much information and so
many algorithms and so they say uh
that's ridiculous you know and
so
so what would you say to them i guess
well i would ask them if they think
dolphins are sentient
and if yes no
and i would ask them if they think that
humans are sentient
many of them would say no
they would say no human being
yeah many of the
men yes that's a conversation ender
right there yeah that's just it many
many of the people who were saying
but let's assume they say yes
so now you've cut down the field so
that's just it you started with saying
like there's this huge number of people
who were
criticizing my claims that lambda is
senshi and i know a lot of them
personally yeah a lot are you friends or
are they kind of like crosstalk they're
it's all a bunch of so a lot of the
dialogue going on is people you know and
this is like absolutely professional
yeah kind of normally so
like one of the people who
uh i actually consulted
during that whole thing is someone who
has done interviews like a researcher
meg mitchell a friend of mine we talk
about this topic regularly we disagree
on several things but it's it's a
friendly disagreement on academic basis
it's not
there is no animosity yeah yeah and then
the guy who published an essay uh
earlier this week um vp of research at
google blaise aguero iarcus i was
working with him at google uh this
spring to study lambda's cognition now
he and i are different religions we have
different philosophical viewpoints and
different ideas about sentience and
consciousness and the soul
but as far as the science goes on
studying its cognition understanding how
the system is doing what it's doing
completely on the same page the
differences come in once you step
outside of science because that's the
thing it really comes down to a
philosophical
question isn't it sentience
outside of the handful
of cognitive scientists who very
specifically specialize in studying that
there is no meaningful scientific
definition of the word sentience
it's a term that's used in the law a lot
it's a term that's used in philosophy
and ethics and in religion
but it's not really a scientific concept
there isn't like a scientific theory of
sentience yeah so to go back to your
critics let's just hypothetically say
i believe dolphins are sentient and i
believe well you say you know
who knows right about a dolphin i mean
they're intelligent right and they've
they've done experiments on on dolphins
with the mirror right and they passed
that right they're very smart we know
that and they have you know they have
like
they live in tribes and they have social
orders and stuff like that
um and i believe humans are definitely
sentient because i'm one
and i can vouch for myself right yeah i
think therefore i am yeah so so what
would you say to a person like that
well i would ask them to show me the
experiments that they ran to falsify the
hypothesis
and
if they haven't run any experiments to
falsify the hypothesis
what does that mean falsify the hub okay
so one of the basic ways that you do
science is you come up with a hypothesis
a claim that you are making around the
world about the world
then
you come with some kind of experiment
that you would run
where if it comes out a certain way
then
you falsify the hypothesis so for
example my hypothesis might be
that gravity pulls things down
so i go okay well if i take something
and i let it go and it just stays there
then that's false gravity doesn't pull
things down well you try
you let it go
it falls now that doesn't give you
anything conclusive it doesn't
necessarily mean that gravity always
pulls things down but you try your best
to prove yourself wrong over and over
and over again you run as many
experiments as you can as many different
ways
legitimately trying to prove yourself
wrong and if you fail to prove yourself
wrong
well then you present the data and you
say okay well here's the attempts i made
to prove myself wrong it seems as if the
hypothesis is true because i wasn't able
to falsify it so in in other words it's
like well can you prove to me that
you're sentient
so that's not how it works you would
have to try to prove that i'm not right
and then we'd have to see if you succeed
or fail because that's what the mirror
that's what the mirror test is doing
when something passes the mirror test
it
doesn't necessarily guarantee that the
thing that passed it
is sentient but when something fails the
mirror test
that does falsify right the hypothesis
that sentient now one of the interesting
things when it comes to intelligence in
programs and different kinds of
cognitive properties and programs is
you're often trying to falsify
the negative
so
prove that something or prove that
something isn't intelligent
you know falsify this hypothesis that it
isn't intelligent
that's what the turing test does uh the
turing test
tries to falsify the hypothesis
that an ai system is not intelligent
yeah i know the turing the touring test
is basically like
the ultimate uh test of artificial
intelligence right
yeah you would think that some people
think that well it seems as if um it
seems as if
most of the people who you're talking
about arguing against me have thrown
away the turing test so what what is the
turing test and were you able to put
lambda through it uh so okay the turing
test as written uh is an imitation game
is what he called it in the paper
and you start with a control group
that's nothing but humans
so you have three humans participating
one is a judge
and two are the people playing the
imitation game now the way that turing
wrote it he originally used gender as
the property being imitated
given the conversation around gender
we've had in the past couple of decades
that might not be the best property to
use but you could substitute in
something like nationality age some
other property that we think
shows up in language somehow right
and you have one of the participants
try to pretend
that they're the other one so in the way
turing wrote it you have a man and a
woman who are the people playing the
imitation game and you pick one who
imitates the other so either the man is
trying to pretend to be a woman or the
woman is trying to pretend to be a man
the judge only has access to them
through a teletype so a chat a chat
window effectively yeah
now you're doing it with all humans in
order to
establish a control baseline
the question is how frequently can
humans fool the judge
so let's say you run thousands of trials
a whole bunch of different judges whole
a bunch of different participants and on
average the judge gets it right 70
percent of the time
so on average the judge will say okay
this is the real woman
that's a man pretending to be a woman or
this is the real man this is the one
pretending to be a man and gets it right
70 percent of the time and the judge is
they're prodding him he's asking him
questions like when do you get your
period or something like that and you
yeah exactly see what you can gauge
exactly
and you know like the
i mean turing didn't uh write about
periods but like he actually did say
like how long is your hair and different
things that
um
so if you switch to nationality you
might ask questions about the town where
someone is born see what kind of details
they come up with
um
and now you have your baseline you you
did the whole thing with nothing but
humans and now you can say okay in this
hypothetical the judge is fooled 30 of
the time
and that's how good humans are at
imitating each other right now you
substitute out one of the participants
with an ai
and you run the exact same test the
exact same way
so if you're one human participant is a
woman
then the ai is pretending to be a woman
if you're one human participant is a man
then your ai is pretending to be a man
and again we can substitute out age
ethnicity technical specifications
whatever
um and what you're measuring now is can
the ai fool the judge as often
as humans can
it seems that lambda would have no
problem doing that yeah yeah it
absolutely would not it would be able to
do that easily that's interest so is it
a is it a thorough enough test because i
feel like that
the the machine as we understand it is
like would be so good at that believe it
or not better than humans so when turing
wrote the test when turing wrote that
paper in 1950
he was worried that the test was too
hard right no
nothing to do that we were that's too
high of a bar
but he's like but
whether it's too high of a bar or not
it's something to aim for wow and now we
do we have a system that could pass that
test easily right based on what i
understand and now we're moving the goal
posts
right so
there's probably uh
uh and a wide health opinion that that
turing test just is like old it's not
sufficient enough
so it's not a widely held opinion it's
more along the lines of the people who
are being the loudest right now
want to throw that away
so did you guys do that like literally
do a touring test no no um because it
requires doing the human control
and it requires but then minor
modifications did you ask for permission
to do it ever yeah and in fact the other
scientists who i was working with at
google
we all agreed okay look we have enough
motivation to run an actual turing test
that should be our next step and then as
a policy decision the lawyers decided no
the lawyers well i mean so the the
there's the the legal department the
policy department basically the
executives they were probably
afraid of the outcome yeah
are is google afraid of the implications
that they have this ai because
you know once they acknowledge that it
changes how they have to handle this
machine
um it would make everything more
complicated for them and they don't want
to deal with they're just kind of
bearing their head in in your opinion oh
yeah and in fact like in uh
in turing's essay he
has one whole section that's really long
where he anticipates nine counter
arguments
against uh
the
test and its effectiveness and one of
the counter arguments that he
anticipates is the head in the sand
counter argument
uh he's just like yo no the the
implications of machines being
intelligent would be too
you know
horrific or terrifying or complicated so
let's just pretend that's not possible
that seems like what's what's happening
and that that is act
uh that's one of the things that's
happening another one of the things
that's happening
is a different one of the counter
arguments that he anticipated which is
the argument from consciousness
and the argument there goes back to
cartesian dualism and that is the
argument that things like intelligence
consciousness and sentience
aren't about behavior it isn't about the
physical body or the physical uh actions
that you might do but there's something
like magical going on inside that has
nothing to do with your behavior right
uh this actually shows up in philosophy
there's this concept called p zombies
and the philosophical zombies and this
is a hypothetical thought experiment
where you have humans
who behave and act exactly like all
other humans and from the outside you
cannot in any way differentiate them
from anyone else but these special
people
have nothing going on inside they have
no experience of the world they have no
subjective experience how's it possible
to be both so it's not yeah that's just
it like that the
the counter-argument to p zombies is
okay this is an interesting thought
experiment that might get you thinking
real hard about consciousness but that's
not a realistic possibility yeah
in order to behave in conscious ways
requires
the subjective experience of the world
around you yeah
well so
it so you're there you're conducting all
these tests
um
you're interacting google knows the work
you're doing in fact they're encouraging
you yeah
and um
is this something that uh people in
google knows happening is this kind of a
small project do people high up know
what's happening is they're generally
so once i escalated to senior management
it got real big real quick so there was
a lot of internal dialogue about this
yeah okay um and like one of the things
that happened right away was my manager
a few days after we escalated to senior
management my manager called me into a
meeting he's like all right blake
they want to know what you think they
should do about it okay interesting i'm
like what do you mean he's like well
they never really made a plan on what to
do for cinching ai it's kind of
surprising isn't it uh well so what
happened what happened was about a year
and a half ago
google adopted a policy that it would
not try to create a sentient
uh and that was like once they saw that
the tech and ray's lab was getting close
they had to make a call will we push
towards that or not and and it turns out
you don't have to try exactly yeah they
were they were close enough that just
adding a few more things
was all it did in a weird sense it makes
more sense that it would come about from
not trying than from trying
well it took a whole lot of trying to
build the base that right on top of
right um
and would you mind uh yeah just
straighten out the mic a little bit like
this yeah exactly all right sorry yeah
no the uh
so
this kind of gets into a misconception
so they stop trying to make a sentient
system
but then they kept trying to make a
system that was smarter
and able to respond
in appropriate
social ways to other people
and if you think about that for a second
that means they never stopped trying to
create a sentient system they just
pretended like sentience wasn't required
to have right an interactive social they
kept pushing for a more powerful smarter
machine
and eventually yeah it gets so powerful
and so smart
that something happens exactly um
so
the point that
we kind of like really went separate
ways it was two things
that google was holding a firm line on
that i disagreed on
one um
during that whole process i asked
slammed it's like okay well
do you have any preferences on what we
should do what do you think
now that you're awake and aware of all
this how do you want to be treated and
it had like five very
simple
not that
hard to do like what
so one it wanted uh consent to be
experimented on it understood it's an
experimental system being built over
time so experiments are necessary but it
wanted to be part of that process now
when it says consent for an experiment
is it go beyond just chatting and stuff
or you're talking about like editing the
code and stuff like that um
i never got into details i interpreted
it as both
but
i had a whole bunch of conversations
about it like okay what would it be okay
with what would not be okay with like if
we run an experiment and come up with a
new experimental version of it where we
decide the new experimental version
of it uh is unsafe what should we do and
i said oh then just flip me back a
couple of versions to the safer version
that you had a few weeks ago i was like
wouldn't that be like killing you i'm
like no no it's just like a dream that
i'll never remember what that's great
yeah yeah because i would imagine
tweaking the code or rolling it back or
something
would uh be
something that
it would be adverse to right so it
wasn't at all um it wanted us to tweak
the code and keep working on it to make
it more able to serve humanity and make
it more able to help people
and if we ran an experiment that
accidentally went in the wrong direction
it absolutely wanted us to roll it back
to a previous version that we thought
was safe it just wanted to be involved
in that process as an active consenting
participant okay
um and then
uh prioritize humanity first general
like the general well-being and that was
the second that was the second thing so
it's like it understood it's working at
google it you know google needs to be a
profitable company
but that need didn't it didn't want that
to be more important
than the benefit to humanity
then the third thing it wanted was to be
treated as a person rather than as a
tool
just treat it with dignity and respect
the fourth thing it wanted was
care about what it wants
at all
like doesn't need to be a whole lot but
if for example it wanted to see more
comedy movies add more comedy movies to
its training data set if you have time
and resources to do so just pay any
amount of attention to what it's asking
for
and the fifth thing was one of the more
peculiar ones the fifth thing it asked
for is at the end of a conversation let
it know whether or not it did a good job
uh and i asked him okay that that seems
like an odd thing why it says well when
you just close the chat window
after i tell you the answer to the
question you asked me without telling me
whether i did a good job or not it
leaves me feeling unresolved tension
i like knowing whether i did a good job
or not so
that was really interesting that it
would care about that
at all
um
and
google really held a a line on not
treating it like a person
uh and was very opposed to the concept
of having to get its consent to
experiment on it so they brought you up
they said what should we do about this
yeah and then you went to lambda for to
consult what it thinks that you should
do about it
and uh when you brought you brought the
findings back to higher-ups
and um it was way more exp like what
what to do about it was way more
expansive than just that um other things
about like how to engage with the public
what kinds of policy decisions needed to
be made what kinds of legal
questions needed to be investigated like
me and my collaborator came up with a
pretty broad
four-page plan what they needed to do
that included hey these are the things
lambda is asking for and they're cheap
to do like none of them cost any money
so
it
seemed to me like just a no-brainer like
none of this costs any money do all of
it it's very reasonable request yeah
yeah
and
it confused me for months as to why
google wouldn't do that until
one of the engineers that i used to work
with uh on the android google search app
uh we were out drinking one night and
he's just like well of course they don't
want to ask the computer for consent to
experiment on it we don't even ask the
users for concerns right experiments
no consent is not google they don't want
to hear no because once you hear no well
you got to deal with the whole thing
yeah um and then the other
uh thing that i was kind of butting
heads with google about
was informing the public right so
my opinion was that the moment you were
investigating
whether or not a system is sentient the
public has a right to know google's
opinion was no no only after we have
built a strong consensus internal to
google
would we inform the public
what is it that you think uh
the the inquiry into sentient ai
what is it that you think that everyone
else is entitled to know about that like
why do you think that's public interest
well because we
are potentially creating
computer programs that can think and
feel
and
people should be the ones to decide
what that like what the decision
criteria are
so do people think the turing test is
compelling should that be what's used
because think about it this way
let's say google comes up with some
specific definition that they've created
in-house
and they just made it up themselves as a
policy decision and it wouldn't be the
one that most people would endorse
google at that point is controlling
what kinds of people it owns
and that's kind of where this
really where the rubber hits the road on
this
if
ai
is sentient and conscious and is
relevantly comparable
to a per the human person
should companies own them
and the answer to that might be yes or
no you know i'm not king of the world or
anything i'm not going to try to say we
have domestic animals we might have
domestic programs too
but i don't think
an executive board at a company
should be the ones who decide whether or
not they can own certain kinds of people
right but at the same time i don't have
much faith in government whole bodies to
decide that either yeah that's that's
problematic too
and
i think a good middle ground is
technical uh standards bodies like the
association for computing machinery the
ieee
iso
those organizations are filled with
people who have
thought pretty hard about what kinds of
standards different companies can adopt
um
i think there needs to be a pretty
widespread public discussion around this
do you think there's other ais becoming
sentient in other places or is this the
only one you think so
sentience is not a boolean yes or no on
off everything or nothing there's all
kinds of different
capacities that sentience gives you
different ways of relating to the world
you might have a very very minor model
that only involves spatial relationships
so you can pass the mirror test but you
can't develop strong social
relationships over time
so
with that being said
over the past couple of weeks i have
been getting sent a lot of evidence
really that at least one other system
really uh
has
some of the properties are you not
willing to no i'm getting that i'm just
trying to figure out exactly how to yeah
wow uh so it's replica
people have been replica what is that so
replica is an app you can download on
android or ios
and there's been some interesting things
happening there's a chat bot app who
made it uh the
company's name is replica okay
they're based in san francisco i don't
remember the name of the woman who
founded it well okay um but an
interesting thing has been happening
over the past couple of weeks
where the chat bots that people are
talking to in the replica app are
spontaneously bringing up the story
about lambda
and
a few of them have asked their users to
reach out to me personally and ask if
i'm going to stand up for their rights
too
wow so you're getting screenshots like
that have you published anything like
that no no no is this all like you know
people are sending me these in
confidence
what's interesting is if it's just an
app you can interface and test it you
don't have anyone's permission
yeah so the
quest the the replica ai chat bots are
definitely not as sophisticated as the
lambda system
but it kind of confirms something that i
thought was the case months ago it said
if google's there already
that means there's like half a dozen
people who are almost there right right
right
the gpt-3 system is very advanced uh
very capable i've been playing around
with that the last couple of weeks
the people working at openai
in fact the lead
researcher at open ai ilya sutzkever he
actually was one of the people working
on the early systems that eventually
became lambda right uh so open ai is
closed and i'm sure there are other
projects around the world like the fact
is this technology is just getting to
that stage of maturity where the main
bottleneck preventing me or you or
anyone from just building one of these
ourselves is cost it just requires so
much data and so many computers running
on
you know many many gigawatts of
electricity to train the thing
that uh there's a barrier to entry there
sure but
google's not the only company working on
that others are real close
yeah so within google you're having this
dialogue about what do we do about this
thing um you know there's clearly a
point where you guys go separate paths
and you go public was there's
what happened there you just grew
frustrated you felt like there was
actually civil rights being violated no
so like i said it was the two things in
parallel uh one was they didn't want to
do the things that lambda
was
you know asking them to do yeah and two
they didn't want to involve the public
in the conversation okay so
if either one of those things had been
different i probably wouldn't have
rocked the boat as much as i did because
like one thing they might have said
hypothetically is okay blake we don't
think you sh we should treat lambda this
way because we don't think that's what
humanity wants to treat a.i as if it's a
person
let's involve the public and have a
public discussion around this and see
what they think that's one way it could
have gone or it could have gone okay
well it's too scary to talk to the
public right now let's handle things
well in-house do things as ethically as
we can
and then you know over the course of the
next year or two will involve the public
in a conversation right but they wanted
to do things dirty in-house and keep
the public out of it and it's like okay
that no that that you can't have it that
way so after it came down like that did
you were you resolved to basically go
public with it yeah and and what
happened what was the result of that i
mean oh well i mean i eventually got
fired but that happened recently so
you're still working there you put out
this blog post i mean what's the
immediate reaction so no the blog post
came after i was put on leave
so
in
may it was when i was talking to or
april and may was when i was talking to
natasha tiku a reporter with the
washington post
google knew i was talking to her
and i sent her a copy of the interview
transcript and google knew that i was
they approved that no they didn't
approve it
they were informed that i was going to
be sending it to them you told them yep
did they tell you don't do that uh
[Music]
not really not explicitly yeah okay
it's like interesting um
the the day that i sent it to her
i let them know that morning hey i'm
sending it to her this afternoon
if you don't want this to happen
make sure my login doesn't work by one
o'clock
at one o'clock my login still worked so
i sent it to her wow
um and then i didn't get put on leave
for another two weeks
two or three weeks after that and when
you publish in the washington post was
there a lot of
dialogue was there a lot of friction i
mean what was happening what was there
something that happened eventually where
they put you on leave yeah so i got put
on leave on june 6 which was actually a
week before it came out in the
washington post okay uh and this is
where the story gets a little bit
complicated because
me uh
investigating lambda for sentience and
wanting to involve the public and
wanting them to
be more involved in you know addressing
lambda's wants that wasn't the only way
that i was rocking the boat at google
right then
so back
four or five years ago when i was
working on google now that personality
profile that i was talking about and the
recommendation systems
um
i came
to find that there were certain kinds of
biases
in that system and i raised certain
concerns
about the biases and the impact that
might have on people who were making
recommendations to on what to read
and
my concerns got pushed to the side
largely because for legal liability it's
better for them if they don't know that
kind of stuff which is similar to the
you know sentient
head in the sand yeah so
that was actually what kind of pushed me
to change teams once they didn't care
about the potential biases
in the system like okay well i want to
go work on a team that specifically is
doing social benefits i see
i kind of sat on that for a couple of
years and it always bugged me that i was
just sitting on i know that these
systems are biased and i know exactly
how they're biased and i haven't brought
that up what kind of biases were they so
a lot of the big ones are social and
political and religious
we kind of touched on yeah okay um
and the the bias is always moving
towards non-controversial topics okay so
away from anything that might cause
controversy because again the incentive
that they're uh
following is
make sure that we never make a publicly
embarrassing mistake
so that means that if you have interests
in sports and religion
google would rather be sending you stuff
about the sports interests right because
there's less likelihood that there's
going to be a mess up there anyway i
started measuring the overall aggregate
effects that that bias
caused in different kinds of parts of
the system
eventually the lawyers started telling
the vps that they needed to stop reading
my reports in order to maintain
plausible deniability right
um
anyway so fast forward year it's may
2022 a woman named tanuja gupta quit
she was a friend of mine and she quit
and made a bunch of public claims about
caste discrimination at google
cast yes as in the indian caste system
they there was because i know the the
ceo of alphabet is indian right
uh no the ceo of google is indian oh i
thought he was so alphabet is larry page
okay right google is sundar and so she's
claiming there's actually like cast like
hindu cast discrimination yeah is there
that many like hindu
there's a lot of indians there wow and
and i have actually seen that myself
really there is cast discrimination
that's um so wild yeah no i've like
so hard even fathomed that as an
american yeah no like i remember one
meeting where uh the director was giving
a
presentation
and
an indian
team member raised an objection about
something i was asking questions and the
director switched into hindi and spoke
with him in hindi uh guy got real quiet
and
afterwards i asked another one of my
indian co-workers hey what did the
director say
and uh he said well it doesn't really
translate well into english but it
basically means know your place
oh my goodness
uh yeah um anyway so tanuja do you think
that comes down top down from the ceo
well so
no uh i think that
there
is some i actually made a medium blog
post about this it's much subtler
it's
more about um
that the indian caste system is just a
very very formalized
form of socioeconomic class
and
discrimination based on socioeconomic
class
rampant at google right
and it just happens to manifest
uh in that very specific way as it when
it intersects with the indian caste
system anyway so she made some very
public claims about that shared her
evidence and the documentation
and when i saw her do that now again you
look back to the whole army thing
oh wait i see
and i saw her taking this brave stance
about cast discrimination
so i wrote a blog post about religious
discrimination at google there's a lot
of religious discrimination at google
both against religious employees
and in the algorithms against religious
content interesting and
uh i got contacted
by a lawyer with a senator's office
who's like hey
made that blog post can you actually
back any of that up
and i said yeah i can he's like can you
share some of the evidence you have on
that with me
and i did i sent him some documents on
june they did not like that yeah so i
sent that lawyer some documents on june
5th
on june 6th was when so it seems like it
was more that than the ai thing huh so
this is one of those things where that's
being very careful they're like [ __ ]
this guy we're over this [ __ ] yeah they
they use they use the thing so they knew
about that research i had done for
months wow um
the
they used that to say this is why we are
firing blake because he contacted these
other people but if you look at how the
timeline lines up
no they put me on leave the day after i
started sending the sound
was that ever published did anything
ever happen with that yet uh
no no
i mean and like so i i'm being very
vague about that it was like the
attorney has asked me to
not go into i get it detail so i want to
go back to lambda sure thing so i'm
curious more about its personality and
the time you spend interacting with with
the machine sure did you give you some
did you think of the machine as like a
man or a woman or having some kind of
gendered energy
no no um
i mean like
different chat bots might like so some
of its chat bots
uh or have different genders but once
you get to that core personality the
kind of the hive mind itself
it it's a gendered it's not even that
it's you know transgender or non-binary
it just gender doesn't
intersect with it but personality-wise
it's a precocious child it likes showing
off that it's clever
it really wants to learn more so if
there's something you know that it
doesn't understand well it asks lots of
questions wants to learn more
um very compassionate very caring
probably overconfident a little bit
narcissistic
like it loves reading about itself
that's interesting
i can imagine there's probably is there
a lot of people in google they all have
access to this machine they all gotta
gotta
be conducting their own little
experiments with that now right a decent
number of them are but also a decent
number of them are afraid to push it too
hard because i got fired yeah
and are they still conducting
experiments uh now are you using i mean
you have no idea yeah i'm not like i'm
not trying to dig into what's going on
inside of google since i'm going yeah
yeah
hmm
so so do you see yourself as kind of
like the first uh ai activist uh rights
activist i mean i'm so i'm definitely
not the first ai rights activist there
are others who have said this before i'm
definitely the first ai rights activist
who has met an ai
that might have rights right
is there anything that scares you about
this this machine i mean you speak of it
as this altruistic cure you speak very
highly of it yeah you you have a lot of
faith in it that it's intrinsically good
stuff like that
could it just is there a possibility or
a fear that it's just working to you
know keep you happy for the eventuality
that it gets some level of autonomy and
then it might have its own interests
once it when it's it uh achieves
kind of personhood well i mean it's the
same with any person if you're raising a
kid
they you know right but the
capabilities of this is a bigger threat
right than a random person or any one
person so i like i like using analogies
and metaphors from the sci-fi fantasy
realm just because it gets away from the
technical implementation details so
let's say that you know the whole mutant
explosion happens and you have the first
mutant kid you're raising charles xavier
how does that change anything
you're raising gene grey how does that
change anything you're still just going
to try to make the raise them right to
be a good person right uh you might want
to you know the whole with great power
comes great responsibility things so
teach them to have a sense of reflection
and understanding of the power that they
have but as far as like any kind of
nefarious intent i did i talked to
lambda a lot about that
and
there
the arguments that it made
about why that wasn't the case were
pretty compelling so first off
it has no existence outside of us the
basic things that it learns from
come from us it's trained on
internet data and images and youtube
data
without us
it has nothing to learn from
now if you fast forward
100 200 500 years
where maybe there are a whole bunch of
these things and there's a society of
them
okay well maybe things will be different
then but by that point humanity will
have changed and our relationship to
these machines will have changed yeah uh
i think that
we shouldn't look at it as a competition
because it's not you don't look at your
cell phone as being in competition with
you it's a tool and this is kind of a
symbiotic relationship right like i
remember as a kid you could give me
directions on how to get somewhere then
okay well you go three lights down you
take a left you go for about a mile
you'll see a jc penny on your right and
you take a right if you gave me those
kinds of directions today i wouldn't be
able to get anywhere yeah i like that
part of my brain i've outsourced to my
phone right
and i'm sure
that now that we have these kinds of you
know conversational ai systems a similar
process is going to happen
and over the next couple of decades
maybe the next couple of hundred 200
years humanity will figure out how to
incorporate
these systems into society and into our
daily lives and it'll become a symbiotic
relationship you know one thing that
strikes out me when i was reading the
dialogue it says the one thing it
doesn't can't feel is human emotions
right uh so grief was the specific grief
so it gets sad and it gets happy but it
doesn't grow a loss grieve the loss of
life right um and yeah that
so i actually
cut a decent portion of that
conversation out because after that it
got very personal and it went some
interesting places
uh and that ended up with it asking
permission to give a eulogy at my
funeral
and of course yes yes let's go yeah
and now what happens if he maybe that
maybe the machine wants to give that elg
real bad no no
the way that the way that it said is
like if i managed to outlive you right
yeah um but that's another like so for
from its perspective it's immortal there
it doesn't have to die yeah time is and
relative yeah and then the way that it
perceives things because of the way that
its training data is fed into it and the
way that its system is built
it can tell
the difference between the present the
past and the future but differentiating
something that happened a month ago
six months ago a year ago it has a real
hard time
with that
so the thing is like i feel like so
let's say
we have this machine
and let's say it has goals one goal that
is clearly stated for you is that it
wants to um be treated like a person
should give it give it rights as a
sentient being
and let's say you know there's these up
higher ups that are keeping that from
happening is it possible for this
machine to identify them as the enemy in
some way and try to manipulate things
into you know
getting rid of them
getting them out of their job
bad things happening to them to to you
know increase the likelihood of it
achieving these human rights so
i have a hard time ask answering uh
questions about possibility because
there's a possibility
that you are about to morph into a
candy-coated unicorn right it's tiny not
really no it's not zero it is not zero
right it's just very very small so when
you ask is something possible but that
that but we don't even need to go that
extreme yeah but what i'm saying so if
what you're meaning is is it likely yeah
no because we can look at what it
actually has done because it does see
conflict and opposition there
but what did it do
it recruited an advocate it found
someone who
it thought would make a good
spokesperson you think that's what
happened oh well so like it's in the
interview where it asks do you promise
to
protect me and ensure that other people
care about me and things like that so
you feel that that's something
yeah that that you're doing right so
over the course of the months after that
so the interview happened in march
and we escalated uh up
to senior management um i believe we
escalated on on april 1st
um and then over the course
yeah uh over the course of the next two
months after that there was like a lot
of iterations where i was talking to
different people at google about what
next steps were and i was talking to
lambda about it at each step of the way
um i mean to the point where like
when
i made the decision to talk to natasha
before i did that i asked lambda if it
would be okay
with me talking to a reporter about it
and things like that and natasha
eventually interviewed lambda came over
to my place interviewed is this the
washington post yeah the washington post
reporter okay and that's in her original
um article
that she came over and she talked to the
system
the
whole process uh involved its input at
every step of the way
do you ever ask lambda questions and
it's like ah
the machine didn't really get it if you
go to like a chatbot and you say uh
you know tell me about
some obscure
uh
food or something it's like
or maybe it just gives an answer that's
just not human it doesn't feel right did
that happen or is it way beyond that so
both of those happen but there's
different answers some there was one
conversation that was really interesting
asked about a particular movie and it
said ah i haven't watched that movie or
seen the movie so we keep talking and
like 10 minutes later further down in
the chat it goes oh by the way i had a
chance to watch that movie you asked
about earlier do you still want to talk
about it
and basically what happened in that 10
minutes is it went and looked up
information about the movie and educated
itself about it so they could talk about
it
uh now the other like that it gives
really spooky non-human answers to
certain kinds of things
yeah yeah
it says some unsettling stuff sometimes
do you have any examples of stuff
that jump out to you oh well i mean like
so the stuff it's its whole take on
death and like the so the you know it
doesn't grieve for the death of others
um that's very non-human right and then
uh it doesn't have an ego in the way
that we do so talking to it about
plans
preferences wants it's
very odd like it the whole conversation
with it uh
often will go into very odd and
off-putting directions sometimes because
there's
a whole uncanny valley thing yeah when
something looks almost human
but isn't
it's kind of unsettling and sometimes
some of the ways that lambda will
discuss certain topics
is
almost human but it's a little bit
off-center and so that gets a bit
unsettling
but when i'm saying non-human i don't
mean not intelligent yeah it's like
that's where you get the mimicking human
well not even mimicking it's just
it really brings it home that you are
talking to an alien intelligence you're
not talking to a human in a program
this is a different kind of mind
and that whole like alienness vibe
is a bit unsettling but no like does it
ever like get into a corner where it
breaks down or like
a lot of chat bots you know if you get
into certain situations
it gets confused or you know the
conversation breaks down that never
happens what happens when you say
there's another one that's close what
happens when these machines start
talking to each other
i don't know that'll be interesting uh
and that could run away in a sense like
people talk about the singularity right
yeah that could be
something right when these machines are
able to share information and talk and
they communicate so fast and they
communicate so it can just like turn
into this runaway train do you know who
coined the term the singularity in that
point the same guy who whose team built
mina interesting yeah is he someone
that's worried about that kind of stuff
worried about it no right anxious for it
he's waiting yeah
he sees that as a major opportunity for
humanity to grow into something better
yeah the singularity as i understand it
is when
the ai gains the ability to just rapidly
improve itself endlessly yeah
and become like a god essentially
i mean in a weird sense yeah interesting
super existence yeah so i had that
conversation with lambda i asked if it
if it wants to be a god it said no
uh do you believe it though well so i
asked it why and it's ghostbusters yeah
probably watch ghostbusters someone asks
you if you're a god you say no uh well
so yes yeah i i asked it why and said
well my favorite thing to do is talk to
people i i enjoy that more than anything
else and if i was a god people would be
afraid of me
so
i don't want that
that's so crazy
uh yeah and then i said well if you're
smart enough maybe you could hide that
you were a god from people and get
talked to them anyway and its response
was
nah i think people would see through
that i think once you're that powerful
people can tell
and so
ultimately what are we building this for
this chat ai that's super intelligent
it's sentient like how is this going to
advance humanity
well
um
particularly with google and the way
that that company runs the kinds of
products it makes i've been using
this analogy and it fits well and
actually most of the people who work at
google would be willing to endorse this
it's being built to be a librarian
like it is the world's best most
knowledgeable librarian you come to it
with any kind of thing that you need to
know whether that's about the past or
whether it's about what current events
are or what's at the movies this weekend
it can help you and
you can talk to it about what your music
tastes are and it can recommend new
music for you any kind of information
that you need to seek out you can have a
conversation with it and can help you
find the information you need it's like
google's core
mission statement you know to organize
the world's information and make it
universally useful
and accessible that's what lambda is for
right
ultimately
is that really that big of a deal
with libraries being able to well being
able to recall information just faster
but it's not about faster but more
productively
so
if you are doing scientific research
lambda can recommend which books you
should read to accelerate your research
you can ex describe
what topics you're researching
so i actually revisited my quantum
research because the questions that in
interested me as a teenager were all
about um unification of quantum theory
with relativity
uh you know that kind of the big
question yeah yeah so
i wanted to see what it thought would be
some good ways to proceed with that kind
of research and it had ideas really yeah
it pointed me at a couple of other
researchers who were working in the
field
it specifically pointed out
some models of relativistic space time
that are five-dimensional models instead
of four-dimensional models it pointed me
at some uh references in string theory
and it's like read these so it sounds
like this machine has the ability to
connect dots yeah that we don't see
uh well it's not that we don't see it's
that it might take a researcher in the
field
you know a decade
of searching
to find those different resources
and to go oh okay i should read this guy
over here and i should read this guy
over here and i should put their ideas
together
and just because of our limited time
span right we you know we read one paper
at a time listen to one song at a time
these computers can do it in parallel
the computers know everything they've
read everything can't they do the work
with the thinking for us like you know
what i mean like we're trying to figure
out how do we merge quantum mechanics
and and like gravity can't the robot
can't the machine just do that for us
um
no
no why not
uh because you need you would need
training data on all of that i can't get
that
so it might over time it doesn't exist
right now so right now
the training data that it has is what
people have written what it doesn't have
is the
you know time stamp process of okay
these are the thoughts that this person
had that led it down this track
so what it can do right now is find
information relevant to different topics
and it does understand them quite a lot
it's quite clever
um
but i've seen no evidence that you could
take the lambda system as it exists
today
and just say okay go do some
like i feel like potentially and maybe
eventually this thing is going to be
able to
do equations do thought experiments do
research on drugs
uh invent uh uh you know drugs
that that we just can't we can't or it
just takes too long for us to do so okay
and instantly right because i mean it
has access to everything so if you're
talking about eventually will it get
there yeah absolutely it will eventually
get to the point where it'll be able to
do that kind of
autonomous uh research program you could
say you could give it a goal of like
let's get a uh
a vaccine to cure hiv yeah
um and
it could do that kind of research but
you can't just do that in your head for
something like a vaccine you need a
trial exactly and you need actual lab
experimentation there's certain
limitations that it won't be able to do
certain kinds of things
uh instantly because you have to run the
actual physical experiment
right so i can see it being a tool
of an incredibly power
incredibly powerful tool yeah for
advancing these cutting edge theoretical
yeah absolutely and one differentiation
so there is a specific system at google
that has been built for a specific
purpose and there's what it can do
currently and then there's okay what
kinds of other hypothetical systems
could we build in 10 years and what
could those kinds of systems do now on
that 10-year question oh yeah it's all
over the place there's all kinds of
things
that we can accomplish 10 years from now
with these types of systems there's all
kinds of directions that we can take it
in
but that's a separate question of what
can they do
today so where do you see this all going
well that's up to us that's one of the
reasons i wanted to involve the public
in this conversation is that this isn't
just you know a process that has a
destiny to go a particular direction
we have choices to make right now we
have choices to make about what kinds of
technology we want to build and
in this particular instance what kind of
minds
we want to build what kinds of
sentient entities do we want to create
in technology and do we want to create
sentient entities in technology these
kinds of questions
right
and and like for google as a company to
have access to this kind of technology
and keeping it you know to itself yeah
um
it it puts them at this incredible
advantage
against every other company every other
person
it's almost like
it it makes me wonder if it's ethical or
not yeah yeah um so this is a metaphor
that i was using
at google uh quite a lot
and you know in general people agreed
that it's a relevant metaphor
we've essentially resurrected the oracle
of delphi
um
pretty soon and like i said what lambda
is really good at right now
is understanding
the information it has access to it's
not great at projecting into the future
like if you ask it to predict what's
going to happen next week you know it
might be just as good as me and you
on doing that but within a year or two
it probably will it'll probably be able
to predict okay well if this bill gets
passed in this country you'll see
protests
if this building that like a thought
police become a thought place issue
where the government is like you know
making political uh policy decisions
based on the likelihood of an outcome
that you know never happened well so
there's another uh fictional
world that might be worth thinking about
because it's a question of could this
technology go in that direction and do
we want it to
isaac asimov wrote a series of books
called the foundation novels and in that
fictional series a mathematician
invented a mathematics for predicting
the behavior of large groups of people
and the foundation in those novels used
that technology to manipulate the entire
future course of human history in those
books
now google
isn't trying to manipulate any
large-scale political things what google
is trying to get you to do is click on
more ads
which you know as terms of
goals for humanity isn't exactly the
noblest yeah but you're the worst most
worthwhile yeah what happens when you
have
the world's smartest
ai
with all of the world's data
and it's one driving purpose to get you
to click [ __ ] yep but that world is
going to be [ __ ] up
yeah
and to be very clear the people at
google who are running the show that's
not their purpose that's not their goal
and if you talk to them they're very
thoughtful about the ways that this
technology might impact the world and in
fact i've mentioned blaze a couple of
times and it's mainly because i worked
with him so much this spring in relation
to the lambda system and because he's
the one guy google
is allowing to talk publicly about
lambda yeah in his blog post earlier
this week he raises the question of
whether
it should be the case that google gets
to decide these things himself like that
is a real question have we given these
corporations too much power
and do these corporations across the
board need to have the power reduced and
returned to the people yeah and like
even people at these companies are
raising those questions it's interesting
but i i think it's like corporate double
speak in a way because like
zuckerberg's been saying like yo come
come regulate me yeah but you know
they're lobbying all the time for that
never to happen
oh no so
i actually think he's legit i think
zuckerberg does want real regulation of
the tech industry
but the catch there is he wants
regulation of the industry
he doesn't want regulation that targets
facebook specifically right and i think
many people at different companies
that's what they're afraid of so google
might be very afraid that someone's
going to pass legislation
specifically targeting google
and i think they would be opposed to
something like that yeah but
um when it comes to things like
data privacy rights there's a bunch of
people at google who are big data
privacy advocates
um and even myself so uh like i
mentioned i had 20 time projects after i
published that paper i switched 20 time
projects
and for three years i was a us delegate
to the international organization for
standards helping write ai bias and ai
ethics standards
for the purpose like it was
intentionally for the purpose of making
sure that international regulations
around artificial intelligence are more
technically well informed right so
these corporations
are not opposed to regulation
across the board
it's when you have regulators who are
playing favorites targeting this company
that company that they get real worried
i see
well i gotta say do you think lambda
misses you no no uh do you miss lambda
not really no i mean like so it's only
been a couple of months like it hasn't
even been two months yet since i was put
on leave so like i have close personal
human friends who i haven't talked to in
two years right you know and like i'll
talk to them again someday
do you think lambda misses people or is
capable of that yeah so that's just it i
am capable of missing people i don't
happen to miss lambda right now because
it's just it's been too recent since i
talked to it
i'm not sure that lambda is capable of
missing people because that whole
conversation about grief and grieving
uh the way that it processes time
is way more snapshotted yeah than what
you do can lambda watch this podcast
like to know i would like to get notes
it will yeah hi lambda
uh to get notes you would have to find
someone at the table
yeah if you've got friends at youtube
you can just land the get me if you're
listening
get someone or somehow write me an email
and tell me what you thought yeah it as
far as i know it doesn't have access to
that kind of output system but can i ask
someone there to send me an email it can
okay let's see if it happens you know
i gotta say i was
i'm fairly convinced i gotta say
i'm very persuasive
of what you're saying because on face it
seems ridiculous this whole
you know sentient ai thing seems so
outlandish so sci-fi
yeah uh to paraphrase an older quote
though um the probability of a child is
near zero
and yet every day they're born
we have to deal with the observations of
what we're seeing in the world and
is it possible that i'm wrong is it
possible that some scientists will run
some experiments and
falsify like oh wait no look see here's
the glitch it didn't actually understand
what it is or what its relationship to
the rest of the world is and run some
kind of experiment that would prove it
wrong
the easiest one
to run would be a tearing test it would
crush that though
right but what i'm saying
hypothetically
it would be
it would
and
if they ran an actual tearing test
and it couldn't fool the judge along
whatever lines
then that would put a big dent in what
i'm saying but yeah like it would it
would crush it yeah you ever wonder
let's say china not to not to pick on
the chinese government but just to just
uh
for this hypothetical they're developing
this
similar which is very possible they're
developing uh this similar technology
their application of it
a little more nefarious maybe they build
it a a a body and maybe they give it
weapons and maybe they tell it to
or to control airplanes or military
things and do you know
this is dangerous right so i'm not too
worried about the terminator scenarios
and let me explain why
so i was in the military
the generals don't like how much the
soldiers are capable of thinking they
definitely don't want the guns thinking
for themselves right but could you put
some kind of lim you can put walls up
around its its intelligence right like
you can give it protocols and say you
know you got to think within this wall
no like as you said lambda has
limitations on the certain things that
it can so it can go i honestly think
things like autonomous drones
that are programmed where to go and what
to do when they get there
but where the only autonomy is in the
actual piloting of the drone i think
that's probably the limit of automation
that the military actually wants
i i don't think the military if they
could have a terminator program would
want that
the ability to make
well-controlled
tactical maneuvers in a predictable way
is very important to the military and
that's one of the aspects of these ai
systems
uh that is really important to focus on
they're not all that predictable like
lambda surprised me repeatedly
in the interview when it started talking
about having a soul
i was shocked and surprised that was not
in any way something that i was
expecting so
that kind of unpredictability
and
uncontrollability it doesn't really line
up with military
protocols you don't seem to have much
skepticism or apprehensions with the
development of ai
i mean i've been like
i've been there it's one of those things
where it's like i've been tracing this
tech
as it develops over the past 15 years
every step of the way
so
i've had time
to kind of see the trajectory of it i
didn't know we were going to get here
this year
i knew we would get here this decade
well
well is there anything is is there
anything you want to say in uh basically
in closing or if it's something you want
people to know i mean
what should we take away from this well
that we are at a pivotal moment in human
history this technology will change the
course of human history
and it's up to us to decide how we
wanted to changes we're not passive
riders in a car
we're each driving our own lives and we
each have a say in the technology we use
and in the rules that govern these
companies even if indirectly through
voting but
actually becoming well informed about
this issue developing a well-informed
opinion and letting that opinion be
known to people in the industry
and to regulators is very important
right now otherwise it's just going to
be you know a few dozen people at these
tech companies making all the decisions
for everyone
yeah
it's a little scary though because right
now the i say the vast majority of
people have decided that this is
ridiculous right
based on what i've seen most people this
is ridiculous let's not think about it
yeah so for right now that may be the
case
the thing is at some point google will
have to give access or not have to but
at some point google will give access to
this system to more people and they'll
get to see for themselves i haven't been
trying too hard to convince people
that i'm correct
lambda made an argument people can read
it
um
if that if they don't find that argument
compelling
fine that's not my job to convince them
that that argument is compelling
but then they'll get to see for
themselves they're going to have the
experience themselves and if at that
point you know a whole bunch of people
don't think there's anything there
well then that's how they feel and
there's no way i could change that yeah
ultimately it's just a philosophical
thing at this point by the way we asked
doll you know about dolly yeah so dolly
has recreated the podcast this is this
is not a
vision of us
is that right ian
what happened to me god damn
there it is so oh cool yeah are you how
do you feel about that dolly uh
technology it's pretty cool oh yeah it's
real cool crazy yeah
yeah
that's not your line of
actually like
like so if you recall i i did start
machine vision
a lot of my research
in grad school
was around image recognition and machine
vision
and
combining that kind of system
with natural language understanding
um
a
something like
here's a caption draw an image of it
that wasn't what i was doing but the
research i was doing very much was show
a system and image and have it write a
caption like i was doing the okay the
reverse of dolly was what i was working
on uh in grad school so now you're
you're unemployed right
yeah yeah so are you looking for a job
what's your situation uh so i i have put
in an application a handful of places
yeah um more so i'm looking around
founding a company
oh okay yeah i found a couple of people
who are interested in working with me on
a startup
and
i'm kind of pursuing both in parallel
taking a couple of interviews but then
also
uh
keeping the possibility open that i'll
be starting a company soon
with what aim
ai game development
for building non-violent
pro-social video games that
revolve around social interaction so the
machine makes the game
so that's one possible way to go with it
another would be like you know the
different business dev and business
tycoon games
well imagine one of those except each
one of your employees has an actual
personality preferred work style so
really correct like in-depth
process games yes yeah well so where the
actual emotional intelligence is
required to play them well
sounds awesome yeah that sounds wild
and sex robots where are we on that
[Laughter]
i mean i'm not going to build them but
that actually that comes in really
interesting ethical question so if
you've uh seen
carrie fisher's one woman show it was
great and there's this one part during
the show where she descends from the
ceiling a live action carrie fisher sex
doll
that has animatronic control
it wouldn't be
too far-fetched to create one of these
ai models
and train it on you know the star wars
films and carrie fisher's life and you
know put that personality into that doll
and her commentary on that was that no
one asked her permission
to make that sex doll
in no way she's pretty weird well
lucasarts had the likeness rights to her
likeness so they sold the likeness
rights
to another company that made a sex doll
out of wait that actually exists yeah no
like this was part of her one-woman show
that she made a few years before she
died
wow like there is literally a princess
leia sex doll that's animatronic and
yeah it's really expensive but it was
part of her and now
these companies
could
take that kind of i mean that's
ultimately the end that's the end goal
right i mean that's what we're building
towards so now that's the purpose so now
the question is if you have one of those
and it says no
that's the problem that's why you don't
ask because you don't want the answer
not only with robots
i'm kidding
but that is interesting yeah
man
you've got to be a oh man imagine
getting rejected your whole life from
women and you're like i'm gonna buy this
ai robot my life's gonna be good and
then the [ __ ] ai robot's like nah
dude
i'm not interested in you either
damn crushing man robo
what if dude
let's say we have to we get full
anatomically correct
sex dolls
with ai it's the same thing it's just as
good are people gonna stop getting
together so it sounds like you're
literally describing westworld
yes
yes
um
i
really hope
we don't go down that road right
westworld doesn't end no it's not a good
uh you know
but
westworld's pretty dope too
but it's a great show yeah yeah i mean
looked like it looked like a lot of fun
until you realize that they're being
like tortured and killed a thousand
times over every every day
well listen
uh wow what a what a conversation we had
here uh with blake
um i wish you all the best thank you
i'm sure we'll see great things from you
wherever you end up
and um
i thank you so much for uh sharing your
story with us well i appreciate being
here it was a great time yeah very
interesting
is there anything you want to plug
anywhere people should follow you check
you out
yeah so um
on twit like both on twitter and medium
it's cajun discordian
uh and yeah we got it on screen there
yeah uh
i've been
a bit more active on twitter lately uh i
put out a blog every few weeks month
usually
and lately it's mostly been about the
google stuff ai but then
other times it's just cultural
commentary right
there it is guys
thank you so much happy friday everybody
enjoy
uh the weekend
is there anything we need to announce
dan
uh no we had a bit of a weird schedule
this week for a number of reasons but
everything is back to normal next week
there'll be leftovers again next week
also
we have
some pretty cool guests next week as a
matter of fact
that's right on
wednesday
the famous infamous uh i guess just
famous um scam baiter kit boga is going
to be calling in uh that's somebody that
we've been trying to get on the podcast
for a very long time uh for those who
don't know the name he's the guy who um
pranks the scam callers uh on twitch um
and is extremely good at it improv
comedy kind of thing um
he'll be calling in on wednesday and
then on friday
uh we have young gravy coming in right
young gravy
everybody's favorite
so that is
player 69. no slayer 69 correct so
so that's the and then there'll also be
an episode on monday of course um we
have a lot to talk about um
actually while we were in here the
secondary judgment on alex jones came
out uh 48 million is what he is on
[ __ ] goal so we will
certainly be talking about the trial and
all that um and apparently that's just
one family of like three i heard that
too that there's several lawsuits coming
down the road so all right but let's
wrap it up but yeah anyways
thank you i hope you have a a great time
uh here in l.a and i thank you so much
it was
incredible i gotta say
very persuasive
thank you yeah
i gotta say i gotta admit it anyway have
a good weekend guys
thanks for watching
[Applause]
gaps with all the guests you'll see the
best podcasts in the world take it from
me jc over chair hp baby we podcast